yes
yes
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh
um
is
this way
well can you take your seats please
ladies and gentlemen
it's 10 o'clock the inquiry is resumed
um
a few housekeeping announcements same as
yesterday there should be a fresh
attendance list circulating today so
please
put your details on that before you
leave
and if you've got a mobile phone with
you as i said yesterday please make sure
it's switched off or on silent whilst
the inquiry is sitting thank you
now just in terms of a few few documents
that i've been given um i've been handed
a schedule of suggested conditions
um
with the appellant's comments on them so
thank you for that
um i'll go through that as soon as i can
and see if i have any comments that i
want to
give you
on that
um
just check mr foster did you receive a
copy of the suggested conditions good
thank you
[Music]
the only other documents that have been
passed to me it's a
bundle of assorted documents
from the rule six party which i'm told
by mr foster are
blown up versions of
photographs and diagrams which are
already in the evidence
and some stills from the video so once
we
get to hearing the
rule six parties evidence you can go
through that for me please and i know
that the other parties have got
copies of these as well
[Music]
uh
miss misread the redacted
appendices of mr blair please yes
so unfortunately they're not paginate
they're not tabbed up no no so um just
sorry okay
so just just in respect of handing the
ones that you've got back yes it might
be helpful for cross-examination
purposes and particularly
the main i'm not referring to
photographs and the one that i am
referring to isn't problematic in that
respect if you perhaps use the ones
yes i'll i i won't do anything with the
ones i've got just at present but
obviously i will
not continue to use them now we've got
these thank you so thank you for those
and similarly mr foster i think there
were some
redacted photos that needed to be
submitted
a few from the rule six parties um that
wasn't photographed so that was the um
time-lapse video no it wasn't simply
that there were some of those later
photographs that that you submitted in
in the in the evidence
which was either called last-minute
photos or or something along those lines
i can visualize at least one
van parked on a foot way with the
registration plate clearly visible so
that's been redacted yeah okay well i've
not received copies of those so you
don't need to give them me right now if
they're not to hand but can you just
bear that in mind that that will need to
come up at some time thank you thank you
yeah sir i'm so sorry we i think we've
just handed you three copies of the same
thing one of them was actually for the
council
six parties so they can switch their own
copies i must admit i didn't really look
at what you you've handed me so one if
you just keep one of them if they say
three so i want one yeah
right yes that makes a bit more sense
doesn't it thank you
um
okay so that was those points
the only other one i wanted to raise at
the minute was the draft timetable that
i asked the inspectors case officer to
circulate so i could have your comments
on it
um
i drew it up on the basis of the time
estimates that i'd been given
i added in a few of my own thoughts
where there were a few gaps
and although i haven't got a hard copy
of what i sent i am conscious of the
fact it left mr pycroft in purder over
the
the weekend which wasn't ideal but
i couldn't see anything
else on the basis of what i'd been given
so
thoughts from anyone please so far only
in respect of the rule six party that i
think i allowed a little bit of time for
questioning i'm sorry excuse me sir
could we speak up to the mic thank you
so sorry that's better isn't it yes
and start again i think i allowed some
time in my initial time estimates for
questions of the rule six party yeah um
the way that i may deal with matters um
is in the same way that i've dealt with
third parties which is it may be that we
take a careful note of what is said and
i pick them up with mr blair now i can't
exclude that might have some points in
terms of clarification and so on um i've
put an hour there i think um
but i think it's fair to say that's
probably well on the generous side
because i'm not intending to carry out a
formal cross-examination of the rule six
party if that assists
okay well
obvious obviously it'll be what it what
it'll be and we will we'll just have to
keep tabs on progress as we move forward
but in general terms the way it looked
to me is we'll
hopefully complete
both council witnesses today
it may take the whole day
at the upper end of your time estimate
for questioning cross-examination if it
doesn't take that long then we may be
able to start hearing from the rule six
party today and things may concertina
but equally if questioning uh get gets a
little bit lengthy it may expand so
really that's why i i put it as i did
it seemed to me that going into next
week is is a given at the minute it's to
to how much of next week and what we
actually do next week but it did seem to
me that two possible times for the site
visit were going to be tuesday afternoon
or wednesday morning so it was really to
get parties views on the suitability of
those times
for
undertaking
the accompanied and any unaccompanied
site visits
so i'll take some instructions if i may
in respect of that point and and perhaps
revert
to the morning break
okay mr parkinson so if i could do the
same just um a couple of things on the
timetable on tuesday
next week i understand that and we
couldn't start until 10 30
due to room availability okay i don't
think that's gonna make a massive
difference but i just wanted to note
that
and i'll also take instructions on on
the site visit
yes
mr foster any views from the rule six
party on what i said in that uh draft
timetable
we're thinking tuesday afternoon would
be good time excuse the afternoon
thursday morning is always a good time
well
we're clearly not going to be in a
position to to do
a thursday at least not this week
because uh well obviously we're still in
the throes of hearing
evidence i don't want to do a site visit
until i know what the views of all the
parties are on various matters
and the way things are looking it's
unlikely that we'll be going um through
to thursday of next week so we'll we'll
have to see how things go but let's at
the minute
pencil in
possibly tuesday afternoon
two o'clock-ish probably
um so you mentioned thursday next week
and also in the email
looking
unlikely hopefully that they'll be
needed but i just wanted to flag that
unfortunately i couldn't do that
thursday okay
okay well thank you um
in terms of the site visit just one more
thing for me to say there i had asked
prior to the inquiry opening for the
parties to work together to produce
a suggested site visit itinerary i did
mention that yesterday
and i've got a copy
of it here
what i also did ask for though was if
there were any particular times
that any locations
should be visited that's what i wanted
to know if the parties were keen that i
saw
particular locations stretches of road
or junctions whatever at a particular
time i can't guarantee that we can
do the site visit to fit in with that
but
if at all possible then i would try and
do that
so
you've just suggested now possibly a two
o'clock start
on wednesday afternoon
sorry tuesday afternoon mr foster
any particular time
that you would want not to go on to
school time later i'm just trying to be
clear in my own mind so i can program in
an appropriate visit
excuse me sir the school times
are all different
um
king edmond school north towards the
north of
ashton road has a very early start in
the morning and an early leave in the
afternoon and the primary schools have
different
time
end
we're talking about
probably a span of three hours
in the afternoon
except we can't cover every eventuality
but i'm i'm trying to be
uh as inclusive as possible so you know
i'm i'm i'm keen to ensure that we
uh that i see a range of um situations
so anyway
give that some thought i'm not trying to
pin people down now but but let's
let's think about possibly penciling in
tuesday afternoon for a site visit and
we'll just see how uh
how matters progress uh as the inquiry
continues excuse me sir is it a single
um
tour so as to speak
what do you mean by that i said are we
just talking a single
uh i i i i will look at whatever
points of interest people have
highlighted to me and if that means
visiting a particular place more than
once in that afternoon then i'm content
to do that but okay
thank you
right
i think that was all i jotted down that
i needed to just ask the parties about
so is there anything from any of the
parties before we continue with today's
business
miss reed anything from the opponents no
thank you sir
no it's foster no okay in that case then
miss reed we
got through um the evidence in chief
from
council reeves yesterday so would you
like to begin your
cross-examination please
thank you sir um
so just just so you and councillor eve
are aware i'm sure council reeves has
been made aware by his team but um
together with the council we've
attempted to put some tabs in documents
to speed matters up for councillor eves
in terms of locating them and miss
fowler who is from the council is just
with our agreement sitting behind him to
assist with with documents as well
yeah that's fine thank you so um
councillor eves um
good morning um i want to use i think
you might need to bring your mic it's
not just me that's struggling with these
microphones a little bit closer because
i was just struggling to hear you then
um i want to start with your proof of
evidence please could you turn that up
as in the proof yes yes good thank you
very much now you set out in your proof
of evidence that you've been a member of
the development control committee since
2019 14th of may is that right yes
um and at paragraph 2.2
um you
set out
the matters that you deal with
in your proof of evidence and the main
concerns of the development committee
and those have been listed
um a to f haven't they in the
documentation uh are we talking about
the oh hang on
let me go to the right one here
what you say in councillor shaw's proof
she and these are also in the stamps
yes got it yeah the development
committee's main concerns as discussed
in detail in the first and second
meetings because this was reported to
committee twice wasn't it this
application
in respect
sorry to interrupt can you uh refresh me
on the uh
paragraph that you talked about
paragraph 2.2 of your proof 2.2 yes you
say in councillor shaw's proof she
identifies at paragraph 3.7 the
development committee's main concerns as
discussed in detail at the first and
second meetings in respect of the impact
of the proposed development on the local
highway network these main concerns are
listed in the council's appeal statement
and there are essentially
concerns a to f that's listed by
councillor shaw
but you go on to say at 2.2 that you are
dealing with points c and f and you set
out what those are you see that
yes yeah and so in respect to the points
that you produce evidence about
its point c the proposed widening to two
lanes on roundabout one from experience
and local knowledge doesn't work in
respect of rectory road and hall road so
that's your first point in your proof
yeah
at two rectory road ashington road was
previously widened to two lanes but was
reduced back to one due to highway
safety concerns so that's a highway
safety issue that you've identified
there yeah
and then point f was the local road
network is already congested it's not
accepted that current levels of
congestion will be reduced and not
worsened by the proposed development and
then you say these issues are primarily
concerned with congestion i think to be
fair to you that's with the caveats of
the rectory road point that you make in
respect of safety correct
yes right
so
in terms of your proof of evidence your
proof of evidence sets out and we can
see this is your 2.4
the reasoning and basis for the
committee's decision
doesn't it
in respect of those matters
2.4 you say your proof as set out in
councillor shaw's proof in life
development committee's decision the
evidence for this inquiry is provided by
myself and council ashore as to the
reasoning and the basis for the
development committee's decision
yeah
and you also set out in your proof of
evidence that paragraph 1.4 that you
understand your duty to the inquiry and
you've complied with and will continue
to comply with that duty
and the evidence you've prepared and the
opinions expressed in the proof of your
true opinions understanding and belief
absolutely that's still
it's the case is it yes okay and so on
that basis what we can
take from your proof of evidence is that
it sets out the council's full evidence
in respect of points c
and f
deals with the other points
a b
d
and e that have been identified by the
council correct
and the council does not seek to rely on
any other matters other than those that
have been dealt with
by you and councillor shaw in your
respective proofs of evidence
in support for the committee's decision
yes thank you very much
um and um it's also the case then just a
matter of clarification
and we know that um it was
initially the case that the council
produced evidence from mr flexman a
professional highways consultant yes
he has and we'll turn to it later
now produced a statement of common
ground
um with
the appellant
where his concerns have been resolved
now he initially um included to his
proof a number of appeal decisions
but you now
on behalf of the council
you don't rely on any appeal decisions
do you because you've not referred to
any to support the judgments that you
have set out that i'd have to defer to
our legal counsel no no well you i'm
asking about your evidence because
appeal decisions can be material
considerations but if they are we need
to know
why what paragraphs are relied on and
how they are similar and moments ago you
indicated to me that your proof of
evidence sets out your full evidence
that you call in support of the
council's reason for refusal
you do not now rely on any appeal
decisions do you in your evidence to
support the judgments that you have
reached no
good
thank you right capacity and congestion
we know that
um the matter was reported to
planning committee on two occasions with
a recommendation for approval wasn't it
it was
and on the first occasion it was uh the
master was deferred to seek
clarification of a number of points that
i understand members wanted
clarification in respect of yes that's
correct i did actually vote for a uh
deferral you voted for a deferral good
um and if we just just set aside your
proof of evidence for moments and on the
desk there you should have core document
5.1
which is a copy of the officer's
uh second reports committee so it's the
officer's
feedback uh it's the officers
could you give me an indication with the
amount of filemaker
5.1
it's the report to the development
committee of the 24th of june 2021
and it's pages 6.4 and 6.5
which deal there's a heading impact on
the local highway network
i'll just ask you to pause there while i
get that i think i've got the right
so six four and six five yeah
yep okay and the relevant sections just
just when you're getting the context in
full because i'm not going to clearly
read it all out now start at 2.13 so and
those those points go over the page to
2.27 in respect to the full context but
i'm just going to take you counselor
eaves
to
a
couple of paragraphs um within it if i
may
um the first one
is we can see at paragraph two point
we can see at paragraph 2.15 at 6.4
that the committee were advised that the
highways authority had considered the
transport assessment and addendum
and are satisfied that the proposal
would not result in severe impacts on
the local highway network
as the legal advice has set out the
highway authority's consultation
response which advises no objection to
the proposal carries significant weight
now i know that your position is that
you disagree with those conclusions and
we'll turn on to the basis for that in a
moment
but just so that we understand the
position you accept presumably that the
view of the statutory council t
should be accorded significant weight
uh can i just clarify there because one
of the things i think you're giving a
bit of misdirection there is the uh the
proposal would not result in severe
impact of the local highway authority
this was covered yesterday that this is
not actually under the ecc uh brief to
clarity classifiers the severe rating
it's down to the
local council
and that was clarified no no i'm sorry
that that's not quite the position
council reeves the highway authority you
understand is the statutory council t
yes yeah the highway authority provides
advice to the local planning authority
in its capacity as expert statutory
council team doesn't it it does the
highway authority
looks at the transport evidence that has
been produced in the transport
assessment and the taa
and they form a judgment
as to what they think
the impacts on the local highway network
are
don't they
and they communicate that's the local
planning authority
and then they also form a judgment as to
whether
those impacts the residual cumulative
impacts on the local highway network are
severe and they provide advice to the
local planning authority
in respect of that matter
and then the local planning authority
forms a judgment in respect of the
application as a whole
taking into account the views of the
statutory council team you understand i
do and also you understand that
yesterday we covered the reasons being
why we were questioning the results of
the transport assessment
i started my question with this point i
understand that your position is that
you differ from the view of the highway
authority and we'll turn on to that in a
moment and have a look at the reasons
for that difference
but you accept presumably as a member of
the development control committee
that the views of the highway authority
the statutory council t
should be accorded significant weight i
think considerable weight is used in the
thetford case which is referred to mr
gascoigne's proof of evidence
significant weight in the decision
making process as a material
consideration now he says the rules are
yeah thank you good
now then
um in terms of what you were then
advised we can see
we can see at 2.16
ecc highways raises no objection to the
quality of the transport assessment
submitted and there is no other country
technical evidence that suggests that
the applicant's transport assessment has
not properly considered the impact of
traffic movements from the proposed 662
dwellings on the local highway network
as appeal an inspector would expect the
council to explain in detail and
evidence
why the submitted transport assessment
is not acceptable and it is considered
that the council could not reasonably
argue this given the highway authority
would not support this position
indeed the highway authority statement
would explain why it considered the
applicant's transport
does in fact appropriately consider
the impacts of the traffic from the
proposed development on the local
highway network now just pausing there
what we have
in this appeal
is we have the highway authority's
initial consultation response where they
offered no objection don't we
yes
we also have a state signed statement of
common ground
from the highway authority
don't we with repellent where it
confirms that position
and then the local planning authority
brought mr flexman in as its
professional witness to examine matters
tweaks to mitigation
were then carried out in respect of the
roach
uh road
uh junction
and the highway authority have looked at
that and what we see
in an appendix we can turn it up if we
need to
later
but what we see in an appendix to mr
blair's evidence
is confirmation from the highway
authority that considering that
mitigation scheme that new one that's
been agreed between your expert witness
and the appellant it remains the highway
authority's considered opinion
that the residual cumulative impacts on
the highway network would not be severe
you're aware of that i'm aware of that
but i'm also aware that we do actually
disagree
uh because uh
for further
excuse me further information yeah well
don't don't worry about that we're going
to turn onto the disagreement but i just
want to
just want to be absolutely clear
and i'm just looking at your
consideration of highway authority's
position
and we'll look at why you disagree in a
moment don't worry but in terms of the
highway authority it is no part of your
case presumably that the expert
statutory council t
in considering this proposal
including in the most recent
correspondence with mr blair
has failed to take into account
any material consideration that's not
part of your case is it
we have since
discovered something that which we think
will throw that completely out hang on a
minute mr uh sorry counselor eaves
you've discovered something that will
throw that completely out are you
referring to the evidence from mr
flexman
uh no the evidence that you've uh
produced
which we will come on to later sorry
you're referring to the your paragraph
40 sorry your page 45 that you referred
to yesterday right but the highway
authority has considered that evidence
councillor eves the highway evidence is
cons and we can actually and there is a
mistake
hang on a moment
turn onto 2.18.
what mistake are you referring to
specifically
we can come on to that when you come to
the evidence now if you are saying that
there is something that the highway
authority as the statutory council t has
failed to take into account material
mistake has been made
i'd like to know exactly what that is
and i'd like you to point me to the part
okay and page reference where i see that
please okay uh what the problem is in
the the page 45
that we uh discussed yesterday
remind me page 45 of this says mr
blair's
there was this this technical
industry technical note whatever so
where am i going to find that it's
appendix 14. appendix 14. yes
evidence thank you
which is junction modelling results from
tetratec amended
modelling yep
someone's taken my sticker out sorry
there we go
the problem that we have
is that when we look at
the delay
the average delay
if you look at the
max q
your
and the
uh
evidence of mr blair and the recent
evidence that we've had
for tweaking on the
roundabout that goes into daley's road
um
that actually
that what you've got there the max q
um
the remodeling relies on free flow
through the
roundabout on dalys road yes
well you tell me
that's what the remodeling is for
counselors the question i appreciate
okay so what you actually have now is it
sorry the mistake is is what counts i
miss saxo as comments from behind you
can you the model the model relies on
free flow right being created right by
the tweaks that are done on the
uh
on the road
on the roundabout for daley's road yes
which tweaks are you referring to the
latest ones
which tweaks specifically are you saying
have created some difference that means
the highways authority has not properly
assessed
right these are the ones that were
recent the last tweaks that were done
you all know that no i'm sorry
councillors this is your evidence
you you are trying to identify something
that you say because just to be
absolutely clear the ardent work that
was initially produced
the ardent work that was initially
produced through the transport
assessment
showed a ratio to flow capacity of one
point
1.37
the tweaks the tweaks that were
subsequently made in respect of were in
respect of geometry which mr flexman has
agreed in the statement of common ground
because what had happened was amendments
in respect of the highways layout hadn't
been taken into account in the model so
the model was overly robust you
understand that yes i do right so
do you take any issue with the fact that
firstly the model should reflect the
actual position on the ground now
no right second point is that the model
was adjusted the model was adjusted to
take into account more realistic
trip rates which again were agreed with
mr flexman
again do you
take any issue
with mr flexman your own professional
witnesses professional opinion that
those are appropriate and robust there
is something that has been missed which
i'm trying to actually explain
council reeves
i i i need to make a note of your answer
to the question that's been put to you
not you responding with something else
that you you want to say so please
listen to the question that's put to you
respond to that if there's then
something else that you want to say in
terms of clarification by all means do
that but
please make sure that you concentrate on
the particular questions put to you
that's that's what i'm writing down and
so i need to know your answer to that
you might have to wind that back a
little bit
thank you so so no no issue that we
should actually use
the geometric parameters that have been
agreed between mr flexman
and the appellant and no issue taken in
your proof of evidence or examination in
chief
in respect of
more realistic growth rates and trip
rates that have been agreed as well
between mr flexman
and mr blair you haven't raised that in
your evidence have you
no no so no disagreement there from you
in respect of that either presumably
no right so those are the tweaks that
have been made
to the model
as you say and what that has meant is
that the ratio to flow capacity has
decreased from 1.37 so the 1.37 was the
basis of the highway authority's initial
conclusion no residual severe cumulative
impact that has now decreased we can see
in the table
that's page 45
to 1.14
so
on what conceivable basis what is the
technical reason that you say
then
that the highway authority
has failed to take something material
into account
now i'm so sorry i would like counselor
eaves to answer it rather than the floor
behind yeah i i'm not quite sure why
there has to be so much um muttering in
in the background it's a formal public
inquiry
questions are being put perfectly
reasonably to somebody who the council's
put forward as their witness on this
topic
it's no it's not appropriate for other
comments to come from the floor
please don't let me have to interrupt
disrupt proceedings by making other
similar announcements
uh can i be clear i'm not taking any
notice of anything that's going on
behind me
no okay but but the point is it's
distracting so
it shouldn't be happening
um if i could clarify my point uh on
this because
the the thing that concerns me is that
what we actually have
is on the page 45 of uh
mr blair's
figures
we have a max q rate
that would indicate that the queue
from the whole road roundabout
would go beyond
the dailies road roundabout
so if we have a queue that is created
from junction 4
going into daley's road roundabout
it would throw into question the free
flowing
of the traffic through the dailies road
right roundabout yeah i understand that
that's your concern councillor eves and
don't worry we're going to come on to
look at your concerns in a moment but it
would really help we could just focus
for a moment on the questions
i'm asking you about the highways
authority
the chronology is they considered the ta
in the taa
that was initially
leading to an assessment of a ratio to
flow capacity of 1.37
in respect to junction 4 which is the
one that you've raised issues with that
has now decreased you've agreed that you
agree with the tweaks that have been
made by the expert witnesses in respect
to that so
it was in respect of the highways
authority
and their consideration of the matter
you do not identify any material change
in circumstances
or evidence that could possibly lead
them to come to a different view to the
one that they've reached do you i know
you disagree with it that's a different
point
but that right that is the position
right thank you good
so highways authority position of no
objection statutory council t we agree
significant weight and no material
considerations identified
by you
which
mean
that
they might come to a different
conclusion
correct
that's fair isn't it
good
and then if we look at what you were
told by officers in that respect 2.18
please of the committee report in front
of you
the committee report details the
residual cumulative impacts on the local
highway network as identified by the
transport assessment and addendum which
would remain once junction improvements
that would be delivered
and had been sorry had been considered
it is the case that the ashingdon road
west street hall road junction no
junction improvements could be carried
out
and that the proposed development would
add to cueing and congestion here so
just pausing there that's confirming the
position that the highway authority knew
that there would be an impact at that
junction isn't it by the officer yes
yeah
and then we see this
however the highway authorities
considered the impact carefully and do
not consider that the residual impact
would be severe we've looked at that
point already and then we see this
advice from your professional
officer
although there may be a perception that
the proposed development would lead to a
severe impact on the local highway
network
it would not be adequate to rely on a
perceived impact
to justify refusing the application
as appeal the council would be expected
to explain in detail and evidence why
the residual cumulative impacts
identified by the applicant's um
transport assessment would be severe the
highway authority would not offer
support as they raised no objection to
the proposal and the council would have
no evidence to present and to support
its case at appeal now that was the
advice from your professional officers
but just pausing there that the the key
point that i just want to
raise with you there
is that you were told or advised
expressly by your professional officers
that it would not be adequate for the
council to rely on a perceived impact in
refusing the application weren't you
councillor eaves yes good
um and um you have
um
you have seen um
well it's mr pikecroft's evidence he's
going to be delivering it but mr
gascoigne's proof of evidence and he he
makes reference to
a case which says that
um where
there is departure from the view of a
statutory council t there has to be a
clear and compelling reason
to reach
such a position
you agree with us you understand good
right well let's have a look at what
evidence you've got then uh to depart
from um the position of the statutory
council t
um if we just take aside put aside the
officers report please and turn back to
your proof
paragraph 4.4
yep
and um
in paragraph uh 4.4 um you set out a
point here which was one you expanded on
with my learned friends
in examination in chief
and you say there is clearly an existing
level of congestion
on the local highway network
this has been stressed by local
residents in objection to the
application further the existing
congestion is identified and
acknowledged in the ta
so just just pausing there
you accept that the ta
acknowledges identifies and takes into
account the existing level of congest
congestion on the local highway network
yes yeah good
now um you were then in examination in
chief taken to mr blair's site visit
observations but you understand that mr
blair's role in respect of this matter
has effectively been to undertake a peer
review of the ta and the taa you
understand that yeah
and so
in respect of
in respects of the ta and the taa
and the modeled results set out in those
they account for
sorry because this is what you say in
4.4
they account for the existing congestion
in on the highway network don't they
yes good
and so when we are looking at the
results of the models when we are
looking at the results of the models in
the ta and the caa
and then as subject to the validation
and tweaks that have been agreed by mr
blair
mr flexman and now also by you a moment
ago
the
existing traffic conditions that have
been fed into that model and that are
identified in the ta and taa
are not challenged by you are they
counselor eves
no thank you
because you have not produced any
traffic survey
or any specific evidence have you
and it is no part of your case therefore
to say that the inputs
into those models are wrong
i believe that's the case
so they're right aren't they on that
basis i well personally i have an
objection to that but no no so so hang
on
your evidence giving evidence on behalf
of the local planning authority
having taken into account the suite of
documentation which i'm sure you've
considered extremely carefully
is that the inputs
into the model in respect of
the existing traffic conditions
they are
robust representative
and fair aren't they
i have a different view on that but uh
that is the professional opinion right
well that's the professional opinion but
as we ascertained a moment ago it is not
sufficient to rely on a perceived impact
you've already confirmed to me a moment
ago
that the existing level of congestion on
the network has been acknowledged and
identified in the ta
you present no specific evidence to the
country
the inputs into the model are fair
robust and reasonable you have no
evidence the country do you counsel it
eaves
i believe
that that is what has been produced
i don't agree with it
because of local knowledge and there is
a severe amount of weight that i believe
needs to be actually taken on local
knowledge
and
you will see as things are produced
later on as we go through
the various um applications i'm sure the
uh
rule of six party will uh bring you more
uh on that where there is evidence and
this this is what is the crux of this
no no sorry let's just focus on the
question
let's just focus on the question you
have identified in your proof of
evidence you say there is clearly an
existing level of congestion on the
local highway network this is a point
that has been stressed by local
residents in objection to the
application so you're taking into
account now what residents are saying to
you in respect of the existing level of
congestion aren't you yeah yeah
experience and personal experience then
you say
further the existing congestion is
identified and acknowledged in the ta
and you confirmed to me a moment ago
that you were content that was the case
my point to you is it therefore follows
doesn't it that the inputs into the
model
the inputs into the model
are fair robust and reasonable if you
say so
i'll take is is that a yes or a no
because if no
if you say so no i'm sorry i disagree
with the results of what we're seeing
i'll note that
right so you disagree so i would like
you please well let's look at the
officer's report and i just want to
probe you a little bit on that because
you understand you are giving here you
are giving here the views of the local
planning authority and you understand
your duties to the inquiry council eves
right could you turn up the officers
report please
power 2.14 this time
yes good
and we see this
essex county councillors highway
authority
has independently confirmed that the
transport assessment that has been
produced is robust and appropriately
assesses the impact do you see that yes
i do for example this is the point i
want to turn to
in respect of baseline traffic data
collected by a traffic survey by the
applicant's transport consultants
ecc compares this to data it holds to
ensure that the data is not
unrepresentative
the traffic survey was carried out as an
appropriate representative time by
midweek
not during school holidays and prior to
the pandemic i just want to pause there
i presume that you accept that it is
appropriate
to carry out the traffic survey
mid-week not during school holidays and
prior to the pandemic so before we see
those impacts in terms of homework and
so on that's appropriate isn't it it is
yeah
and you have not identified in your
comprehensive proof of evidence
any reasons
why the survey time
or period was unrepresentative have you
no no
and in fact we know that residents are
particularly concerned about thursdays
because that's been laurie day as i
understand it
yes you're aware that the traffic survey
was carried out on a thursday councillor
eves
i wasn't aware which day it was taken
out no well i mean it says on the front
cover and we can get it out if we need
to but it was carried out on a thursday
and again i presume that's something
you'd support then isn't it in terms of
representing the worst case conditions
i would guess so yes
you
good and next point we can see that ecc
has compared the data
in the survey to data it holds
to ensure that the data is not
unrepresented
you have produced not a scrap of
evidence have you counsellor eves
to demonstrate
that any of the data in the traffic
survey
which has been independently compared by
ecc to traffic data that it holds
is erroneous or unrepresentative
i would
i find that difficult to actually
disagree with
so you agree no evidence
no evidence
no evidence to dispute
the data in the traffic survey as
independently verified by ecc
that's fair isn't it yes thank you
good
and mr flexman was instructed by the
local planning authority as an expert
to represent the local planning
authority and we'll turn on to what
happened there in a little while
but at no point did mr flexman challenge
the appropriateness representativeness
or robustness
of the traffic survey either did he i
believe that's the case thank you
good so that traffic survey and the as
an it and the inputs into the model then
can can and should
be accepted by the inspector shouldn't
they if there's no evidence to the
country
yes thank you
good
and so when we
think about that test that we turn to
at the beginning which is there must be
cogent and compelling reasons to depart
from the views of the highway authority
and the views of the highway authority
should be given significant weight but
it's those cogent and compelling reasons
to depart from the view of the highway
authority
there are no evidenced cogent
and compelling reasons
based on evidence are there
to deport depart from the view of the
highway authority
that the data used is representative
and appropriate
i believe that there were issues that
were brought up yesterday uh that do
actually conflict with that
in in the in respect of the
uh reports that have been produced i
don't have the professional
um
qualifications to dispute them right so
a moment ago you said it can and should
be inspect accepted by the inspector
that means doesn't it that there are no
you are giving the evidence on behalf of
the local planning authority there are
no cogent and compelling reasons on that
basis are there
to depart from the considered opinion of
the highway authority that the baseline
traffic data
was appropriate and representative
that would appear so thank you
good
right
next point
um examination in chief examination in
chief
the specific point
that you
were taken to
related to
observations
in the am peak you recall right yes yeah
and i think you said
your specific knowledge and experience
really related to the seven to eight am
period and then councillor shaw
had informed you and she could confirm
later that it was it was similar from
the period eight to nine o'clock you
recall that evidence yeah okay so just
to be clear
because we know that your evidence is
your comprehensive evidence you're as
supplemented by your examination in
chief
you have not taken issue
with any other period in your proof of
evidence or examination in chief other
than the amp have you
that is what the area that i am familiar
with right you have not you you're
presenting the evidence on behalf of the
local planning authority you have not
produced in your proof of evidence
or examination in chief
any specific reference
or case
relating to any other period other than
the am peak to support your judgment
that the residual cumulative impact on
the highway network would be severe
that is because that is what i'm
familiar with right so that's a yes
isn't it your evidence relies solely
upon the impact in the amp doesn't it
yes yeah thank you
good
um and
just to be um
dealt with that
um and um just want to
have a little think about um where all
of this takes us then
um we know that the issue that you're
dealing with other than the highway
safety point in respects of rectory road
is whether the residual and the words of
the framework and i know you have it in
front of you if you want to refer to it
but the words of the framework are and
the test is whether the residual
cumulative impacts on the road network
are severe you're familiar with that
it's para111
which page is this could you i don't
know what page it says paragraph 111
[Music]
thank you
thanks
we've got that yep got that so test
whether the residual cumulative impacts
on the road network are severe yeah and
then there's also a point about an exact
unacceptable impact on highway safety so
we'll look at that bit later when we
look at your rectory road points but
focusing on the congestion point for the
moment so
you understand counselor eaves that the
test is not whether the
network is subject to a level of
congestion now
it's looking at the position
post-development and post-mitigation
yes yeah
and it's looking at the
insects looking at the position post
development and it uses the words
residual
so what that means is that in assessing
the impacts
you take into account the mitigation
that's proposed don't you
as well yeah
and it's also talking
about
the residual cumulative impacts on the
road network so it's not the
identification of one specific severe
impact it's looking at the thing in the
round isn't it you understand that yeah
this is a problem that we do have in the
planning committee in that when we do
have reports like this brought to us it
just considers the local
aspect it does not consider in the
reports that we have it does not
consider the wider road network we have
nothing in the report that was given to
us with around the wider road network
well sorry i think you misunderstand my
question the study area that was
considered and that was agreed with
planning officers and highway officers
took into account a number of junctions
didn't it it did yeah so my point is
that in considering whether the residual
cumulative impacts are severe you take
into account the impact on all of them
not just one of them and you take into
account the impact
at all times not just one time for
example you understand that so but it's
a balanced judgment taking into account
everything and so just because you
identify one impact
that doesn't necessarily it doesn't
necessarily follow that the impact on
the road network
is going to be unacceptable you
understand
yeah but you only have to have one point
you know in a pipe that's that's uh
blocked for the whole thing not to work
well it depends weren't it how big the
blockage is how long the blockage lasts
and the impact on the pipe as a whole
but that is what we've we have actually
put forward as being the problem is that
there is a point in the in the pipe
where it does block and it does affect
everything right well is it because you
say in the reason for refusal that the
the development would result in a severe
impact on the local highway network
that's not the test is it it's whether
the residual cumulative impact on the
highways network would be severe you
understand i do good
right now then in terms of the and you
also understand that when considering
then whether the impact on the road
network the residual cumulative impact
is unacceptable the test is whether the
impact is severe so we're not looking
for a nil detriment are we necessarily
no yeah so you can have impacts that are
negative impacts but are not severe you
understand that i do good
and um in terms of the junctions that
were assessed
um through the
application and have been further
considered through the appeals process
nobody has taken any issue have they
that this is an appropriate study area
and that together the local planning
authority the highway authority and the
appellant have looked at the relevant
junctions yes good
and um in terms of um
that point then
um i just want to understand actually
and this is hopefully now clarification
because i know you've had mr flexman
assist you in terms of looking at some
of these points i just want to
understand
where the areas of difference now lie
between us the appellant and you the
local planning authority if i may
following that review
can you turn up mr blair's proof of
evidence please
right okay right so um so just what this
is this is just understanding now
where we are so you've got mr blair's
proof of evidence
and i'm sorry i also need you you should
have a little small thin black file
which i can see just in front of you
miss fowler told me to tell you it was
in the small thin black file to
help to assist also we're going to just
have a look at the statements of common
ground now between
the highway authority
and the lpa so there are two of those
okay
okay you have both of those
can i be clear highway authority sorry
not the highway throughout the highway
statements of common ground sir
statement of common ground this is the
one that was
back in november is that the one there
there should be one which is dated
january
yeah i've got four all together hang on
with me 19th of january 2022.
hang on then
yes and then also one day to the 24th of
january 2022. okay so the 19th of
january is the one that i got prior to
the inquiry starting and then the um 20
whatever you said is the one that was
handed in yesterday
different place
yeah i've got both of those thank you
thank you very much sir
right councillor eves um just turning
first please to the
one that's dated the 19th of january
2022 so this is the first statement of
common ground
between the local planning authority and
the appellant
and this is the one that was signed
before before rebuttals were served by
mr flexman
and mr blair yeah
it's the it's the bigger one of the two
if that helps
okay and just to be absolutely clear we
can see on the front page that this is a
statement of common ground between the
appellant and the um the appellant
and rochford district council yeah
yes
and over to the first page although it
was signed by mr flexman
and again this is the one that was
served before the rebuttals
it was signed by him on behalf of the
lpa you see that
yes
and then if we turn over to paragraph
1.1 please in the introductory section
yes
we can see this this highway statement
of common ground has been prepared by
tetra tech and with connect consultants
that's mr flexman's consultants acting
on behalf of the lpa
and the council in respect to the
application you see that yes right so
this is these statements of common
ground that was signed and it represents
the agreed position
between the appellant and the local
planning authority doesn't it
that's what it says yeah good
and um
we can see at paragraph 3.2
and this was a point that i put you
earlier in with which you
agreed
having confirmed that the council does
not dispute the accessibility of the
site is acceptable at 3.1 this is the
point i'd like to turn to at 3.2
it is agreed that the updating of trip
rates growth rates and validating of
base models as set out in mr blair's
evidence
as updated via emails from mr blair on
the 18th of january at 3 19 and 14 sorry
1642 is acceptable for assessment
purposes so there is agreement with the
local planning authority
there is agreement in respect to the
local planning authority that it's those
updated models that we should look to
isn't it to understand the impact of the
scheme that's what it says well that's
the agreement to the local planning
authority isn't it that it's those
updated
models for trip rates growth rates and
validation of base models that we should
look to to understand the impacts of the
skin i can't disagree with what's
written
good
um and we can then see
um
just bear with me
just find the right reference
yeah it's it's 3.3
so there was a a point taken
um in respect to the
ashington road dallas road roundabout
which we'll turn onto in a moment
so that was junction three
but then we see this it is agreed that
the modeling software has been used
appropriately by the appellant at all
other junctions included in the analysis
yeah so that's junctions one
two
and four
and five
yes
okay
well that's the agreement isn't it
between the local planning authority and
the appellant that's what it says yeah
and so
it's there it's those models for
junctions one
two
four
and five as updated for trip rates
growth dates and validation as confirmed
in 3.2 that we should look to to
understand the impact of the scheme on
those junctions isn't it based on the
agreement here
it does thank you
so let's just have a look
where that takes us
and now if you turn to mr blair's
evidence
please
um and
at
page 33 so this is
um yeah at page 33
what section have you put that under
please
put in what section have you put that
under uh so this is where it's the it's
the section
it's section nine and it's um
mr blair's over that mr blair's proof
okay
i'll just take advantage of the lull
there to say that i'd look to have a
mid-morning break round about half 11 if
you're still
going at that time so
i'm not i'm just putting i'm not making
quite as much progress as i anticipated
so i'll do my best but um yep well and
it's difficult with the papers and
things counselor eve so we'll we'll
continue after the break obviously
um
so um right we've got in section nine
and it's pages 32-33
so look where that agreed position takes
is so at 9.3 and i'm sure this is
uncontroversial this particular point
but let's check
um that um
it's talking there about the capacity of
the new site access no issue taken with
you in respect to the site access is
there no good
and um next point
um
page 34
so this is where um we are dealing with
the amblin
roundabout yeah
and you're aware council reeves that um
obligations have been
offered in the section 106 obligation to
provide contributions for improvements
at the amblin roundabouts
yeah i would make a comment there that i
did ask when we had the representative
fromatics highways at
the original
application
when it first came to planning committee
i asked because it was
highly detailed all the other junctions
but the
ambulan roundabout
was just noted as needing improvements
in
respect of doing due diligence as a
member of the committee i did ask
specifically the highways representative
what those improvements would be
and i have continued to ask what those
would be we were given an answer at the
development committee
and that answer was rather short and
pert
um and it was uh it's complicated
now my point on that was that i said to
the lady uh afterwards i said you know
you need to
give us something to be able to look at
here because as committee members we
need to do due diligence and i have
continually asked
what those improvements will be that
roundabout there the reason being why we
asked the question
was because there are two lane
approaches to that roundabout already
and so we were a bit confused as to as a
committee what on earth those
improvements would be and we have never
been given the information as to what
they would be well i suppose um the the
issue for the planning committee and for
you is that you need to be satisfied
that a scheme of mitigation can be
implemented that would resolve issues
there you understand that there might be
several schemes that could do that but
you need to be satisfied that one can be
implemented that achieves that result
yeah
yeah but we should be actually privy to
what those recommendations should be so
as we can do due diligence and we were
never given that option well let's let's
just have a look at the evidence that's
before the inquiry now okay because we
have the modeled results and we see at
9.6.5
of uh mr blair's evidence
that he has um tested
a minor mitigation
scheme
and what he says is that that minor
mitigation scheme
which effectively um it's a curb
realignment
um to
widen the approach so that there is more
capacity on the approach
would over mitigate
by one percent
so what that means
is that that roundabout
will be
or can be brought back into capacity
or the highway authority could use the
contribution he says towards some bigger
scheme if they're also looking at more
general
improvements on the highway network
now i presume that you do not have any
technical evidence
to dispute
mr blair's mitigation scheme
that would bring that roundabout
to operation within capacity
we as a committee we have never been in
a position to be able to question it
because we've never known what they
would be no i'm sorry you've you've had
this proof of evidence you've had this
proof of evidence no i understand the
position of the committee and i know
you're trying to give you but you you
who is giving evidence on behalf
of the
highway
uh sorry of the local planning authority
has had mr blair's proof of evidence
for four weeks and you're also engaged a
professional highways consultant
to rigorously analyze
the appellants case
and you do not produce any evidence do
you to demonstrate
that even that minor scheme of
mitigation
would not be successful in mitigating
the impacts that the ambulan roundabout
i am reliant on the experts that are
around me right so we can agree then
because we know that mr flexman
has said that he has
there are no outstanding issues now
between him and mr blair
if you're reliant on his evidence in
respect of
this junction
the position
of you on behalf of the
local planning authority
is that the impacts at this junction can
be mitigated to an acceptable degree on
the base of the evidence before the
inquiry that would appear to be the case
thank you
can i point out one other issue that
actually is of concern to us with
regards to the ambulance roundabout
uh the modeling does actually um
[Music]
uh come up with uh because we've had an
issue there at the council for this
particular area of air quality
it's very close to being under an air
quality management
situation
the
models that we've had have
that have been produced
would suggest that there is not a
problem with their
air quality around it
however the council does actually have
physical tube air quality measurement
situation in that area
and three of the last four years
those readings have failed
so
it does bring into question
the models on the air quality management
i just wanted to point that out as we're
we're looking at the ambulan roundabout
at this particular point in time as that
is a concern okay but you're planning
statements of common ground between you
and the local firstly there's no reason
for refusal on the base of air quality
as their councillor eaves and that has
what has been written yeah
well there isn't is there there's no
reason for refusal on the base of air
quality i have a concern on that as a
councillor i'm representing
the residents of the area and that is a
severe concern
you're representing the local planning
authority here
and the local planning authority
there is no reason for refusal on the
basis of are you adding a reason for
refusal
i'm just expressing my concern
understood are you adding a reason for
refusal on behalf of the local planning
authority
that can't be done no right because also
it's the case isn't it that the
statements of common ground the planning
statement of common ground and i'll read
it to you it's 5.23.
air quality
it is agreed that the appeal site does
not lie within or close to a designated
air quality management area
and that the impacts from vehicle
emissions that would result from the
proposed developments would be
negligible
it is agreed that the air quality
pollutant concentrations would remain
well below their respective air quality
objectives and targets and therefore no
mitigation is required that is the
formal view of the local planning
authority
as set out in the planning statement of
common ground isn't it
it is but i have uh severe concerns
about the accuracy of that those
personal concerns aren't based on the
evidence that we
at the council are presented with from
physical measurements that's all i'm
doing i'm just pointing that out that
that is a concern that we have that i
think should have been taken into
consideration it's not in there at the
moment as a refusal but to say that it's
not something that would be considered
as an air quality management area is
incorrect because the council have
actually considered that area actually
coming into an air quality management
area in the past it's not one now is it
not at this the first moment of time and
i want to be absolutely clear on this
point because
it goes to the reasonableness frankly of
the council's behavior
are you seeking to tell the inspector
that you
on behalf of the council
now
are adding
a specific
objection
in respect of air quality i'll repeat
what i said i'm raising my concerns i'm
just making my concerns counselor eve i
said before
i don't want to hear you give a rambling
sort of answer if something direct is
put to you
please answer either yes or no then
clarify it then at least i've got your
answer to the question that's been put
it makes my note-taking extremely
difficult if i if i make a load of the
question
and then i don't get an answer to it
you want to try that question again
no reason for refusal
by the local planning authority in
respect of air quality
planning statements of common ground
confirms no issue taken by the local
planning authority in respect of air
quality and i read the full paragraph to
you
no evidence in your proof
or counselor shaw's proof
presented on behalf of the local
planning authority
in respect of air quality
are you without any evidence producing
an additional reason for refusal or
objection
in respect of air quality on behalf of
the local planning authority no thank
you
good
right so let's go back to the points you
do take we've agreed scheme of
mitigation at the ambulance roundabout
can mitigate the trans traffic impact
there of the scheme to an acceptable
degree
next one please back to mr blair's
evidence
um sorry just gave me a second
yeah the rectory road
uh
the rectory road roundabout uh junction
now please
so the rectory road junction
is junction one
and that is dealt with at nine 9.2
9.2
of mr blair's proof there's a heading
there do you have that yes
and
in the
highways statements of common ground
that we took out a moment ago
and which i have just misplaced just
bear with me a sec
seem to have lots of copies of one of
them
um so this rectory road is junction uh
one and this is um you'll recall we were
looking at paragraphs 3.2 and 3.3 of the
statements of common ground before
so this is this is the junction this is
one of the junctions again
where it was agreed by the professional
experts
that the modeling software was used
appropriately
that's the bottom of 3.3
and again trip rates growth rates
validation of base models as set out in
mr blair's evidence you accepted earlier
with the appropriate
models to use now based on the position
of the local planning authority and the
appellant to understand the impacts
and
um in terms of what those impacts are
then
we can see
if you look at mr
blair's evidence and it's
9.2.3
and i'll just be clear i'm going to turn
onto your road safety point separately
in a minute i'm just looking at capacity
at the moment in respect of that
junction councillor eves yes
what we can see there is that
when the revised growth and trip rates
are used
the tetra tech model for the mitigated
layouts this is post mitigation which we
know we need to take into account under
paragraph 111
gives a ratio to flow capacity
of 0.94
in the 2029 with development
and a baseline
ratio to flow capacity
of
1.02
in the 2029 without development scenario
so what we can see there
is that the capacity of that junction
improves
with development and mitigation
as compared to the position in 2029
without the development and without the
mitigation you see that i do
and again
in terms of capacity
the local planning authority
now and bearing in mind it's had this
looked at
by its own professional consultant mr
flexman but the local planning authority
now then
does not take any issue
that
that the impacts on that junction
can be mitigated
appropriately
that's what we've
that's what's here yes
all right
good
so the only outstanding
issue in respect to that junction
doesn't relate to capacity it relates to
your highway safety point it does good
now um in terms of your highway safety
point
um we can see firstly if we turn up
you're going to need now the statements
of common ground with the
highway authority please
this is the 19th of january one is it
the bigger one of the two
the highways authority one which is
november november 2021
sorry there is three
there are three there are two with the
lpa and one with the aha yeah
i've got it yeah thank you
um so with highway thought yeah november
yeah got it thank you
and it's page six please
okay thank you
and at page six we can see
we can see at page six
at 4.8
agreement with the highway by the
highways authority
that the proposed highway improvements
at the rectory road ashingdon road
junction
as shown in the drawing reference there
ending 15a
are safe suitable deliverable
and mitigate the development impacts now
you've degree agreed the point with me
in terms of mitigating development
impacts
you don't take any issue with
deliverability your issue is in respect
of safe and suitable as i understand it
it is right but we can see that the
recorded position of the highway
authority
the statutory council t
is that those works would be safe and
suitable
that's their position
that's what it says
so again in order to depart from that
taking into account the points we have
raised previously there would need to be
clear and compelling evidenced reasons
for doing so
wouldn't that yes
um and um
in terms of um the
mitigation
scheme
in terms of the mitigation scheme um
i have
put a tab in it
but i'll ask you the question you can
check it if you want maybe in the break
um and
um but the art there's been a road
independent road safety audit you
understand undertaken in the ta yes
and we can turn it up if you want very
happy to or you can have a look at it in
the break
but there have been no issues raised in
respect of the improvements for rectory
road through the road safety audit the
independent road safety audit have that
no may i
be allowed to follow up on that
i did in the course of my
trying to figure out the situation here
get in touch with the head of essex
highways
and ask him what improvements had
previously
been done to this junction
he wrote to me and told me that he had
referred this to his team his team came
back
and rather concerningly
told me that there are no improvements
that they he could find
well it didn't take me too much to find
the improvements that i put in my
further proof
uh rebuttal
well we're going to look at those don't
worry because you know we're going to
look at what reasons you've got and
whether they're clear and compelling to
depart from the view of the highway
authority that this scheme
judged on its merits is safe suitable
but there has been an independent road
safety audit undertaken hasn't there
that indicates
that those proposed improvements are
safe and suitable
yes
but my concern is that
if they haven't been
afforded the history
that
the history has not been taken into
consideration and that is a serious
oversight i can't prove that that's the
case but the information that i've
actually been given
would seem that that is the case well
let's have a look at what that is um
because if you if you turn up your
uh
your rebuttal
proof
and if you turn up you've included a
a report
to the county council from ringway
jacobs
yes got it
and i'd like to turn up page two and at
the same time
attached to the highways statement of
common ground
is
a plan a drawing which shows what the
junction improvements are and it's the
one ending 0 15 a
that was referred to in the paragraph
that we discussed a moment ago
okay give me a moment while we find the
paperwork thank you in november 2021
yes it is yes it's it's it's the retro
road improvements it's drawing
it's
one eight five one eight zero dash
fifth
yeah you have both of them i have got
that
and so what we can see
on this drawing
is what the
what the improvements um will be
and first point is
um that the lane widening
um is going to be a formalized
arrangement and as i understand
your proof of evidence when you say that
it was previously used as two lanes that
wasn't a formal arrangement that was
effectively it was it was drawn on the
ground as one lane but people used it as
two
yeah
yes the difficulty that we have with
that is historically
there are residents around there who
have been there for many many years
before the painted island was put in
do recall it as being a two-lane
entrance
and that has been one of the problems
that we've had in getting information
out of essex highways but the
but my point is one has to look at
what's proposed now and assess whether
that's safe you understand that council
i do right so what is proposed here
is a formalized two-lane approach and if
we look at the ringway jacobs report
that you have
referred to
and also the photographs that you've
produced which don't show that
for don't show any formalized too late
entry at the point that this report was
undertaken yeah
what what it says here
is that the concern that they had then
was that motorists were joining the
roundabout from rectory road and
undercutting the roundabout island you
see that that's what it says and then it
says
this is likely due to the position of
the roundabout island so the position of
the roundabout island
combined with a thermoplastic splitter
island that can be overrun yeah yes so
those were the issues identified and it
was a combination
of those two factors that led to that
particular geometry that existed at that
particular time
um being in need of remediation yeah yes
but if we if we look at what's being
proposed here
you can see
on the drawing that's been produced
what's happening here is um firstly
that the um
i mean the route the roundabout's been
widened to allow for two-lane entry
which we've discussed
and road markings are being adjusted but
we can also see in particular that the
road marking
and this is just to the right of
it's the annotation to the right of
ashington road that i'm looking at it
says road marking adjusted
dome central road marking reduced to two
meters diameter
and moved south to centralized yeah
so the roundabout
is changing
in terms of its size and location you
see that
at the the spot in the middle yeah and
so that is going to change
that is going to change the behavior
of the drivers on approach to that
roundabout
as compared to the position that the
highways authority
were looking at in the report that you
produced you understand that i do right
and the highways authority
have looked at this the mitigation
scheme that is proposed
that has also been the subjects of an
independent road safety audit
and they have concluded that this
geometry that is proposed
that is different to what existed before
is safe
and suitable
haven't they
they have have you and you have
you have
no technical
or clear or compelling reason
or evidence do you
to demonstrate that the proposed
mitigation scheme
on its own merit
is anything other
than safe
and suitable
i would disagree with that
and the reason being why
is because if you look it's without the
benefit of the history here which
doesn't seem to have been taken into
account
what you're actually putting
in on the proposal is exactly what was
there before now you look at the
approach on the pavement edge that's not
being moved
you're introducing a two lane there
which effectively was exactly what was
there before
the fact that the spot of the middle of
the roundabout
has been moved
is not going to make any difference what
we actually do have
on the report that was given to
the highways in 2018-19
um is an issue where people were
actually going on the right turn from
rectory road into the roundabout early
now that's not going to change
well let's let's just break that down
um the point that's identified
specifically by the highway authority in
the ringway jacobs report one of the
points that was identified it was a
combination of points
was that it was the position of the
roundabout island that was causing
people to undercut
yeah that position is being changed in
respect of this new proposal isn't it
isn't it yes it is but let me just point
out one thing there if i may
one of the things that is actually
reported in the ringway jacobs
issue is that
there were no
sight line problems
the actual
position of
the cars
going across that roundabout
will end up being exactly the same
whether you've got the road markings
just moved over a little bit
uh okay i'm not an expert but i have to
be honest as a driver i feel that that's
going to make absolutely no difference
whatsoever
i take the point that you say that you
have experts who've done this but might
have serious concerns which is the
reason being why i pointed this out in
my rebuttal that this is actually
returning to the position that the
approaches were before the improvements
that were previously put in place
were done
and that i don't see
how
that this
proposal here actually
improves the safety i i i'm sorry i just
don't see it well first first point
we're not required to improve safety are
we we just need to demonstrate it is
safe you understand okay let's listen
yeah yes second point just look at the
drawing
yeah the issue previously was that if
you were a driver and you were
approaching along rectory road because
visibility to the right
is
good and because of the position of the
roundabout what drivers were doing is
they're looking right they can see it's
clear and they undercut the roundabout
yeah
you understand that was the issue that's
being identified yes right look at the
drawing that we've got in front of us
now yeah what's happening is the
roundabout is moving if you're
approaching as a driver
it's easier
to turn around it because of the
position of the roundabout
and that means that drivers are not
as likely to make
that maneuver so it's a different
kettle of fish
in respect of its geometric layout you
understand i do understand what you're
saying there and i do understand the
report that they put here but i cannot
see how this is not going to return this
to the dangers that were there
beforehand which resulted in the
accidents that are documented well let's
let's break it down
can i
i do hesitate obviously you're you're
full flow but we need a break at some
stage because we don't want the witness
to be on the with this uh stand too long
in one continuous bit so i'll finish
this point and then we'll break please
do yeah so let's break this down you
understand the point so that the first
point is
what is
whether you agree with it or not is the
second point but the first point is that
what is proposed in respect of the
alignment of
this scheme
is different
to the alignment
that existed previously
that the highways authority took steps
to resolve as a matter of fact on the
ground yeah yes right thank you
second point
so not the same but different
second point is that
this
alignment has been assessed by the
highways authority
it has been assessed through an
independent road safety audit
it has been assessed by the appellant
but also mr flexman the local planning
authority's own professional witness
raised no issues in respect of its
safety in fact he says in his statement
of common ground all issues are now
resolved with the appellant
you have no specific evidence or clear
and compelling
evidence or reasons do you
to positively demonstrate
that this proposal is unsafe
i have a compelling reason
to believe that it is unsafe one of the
reasons being why is because
i'm not sure
that the um
people who have actually done the uh the
survey on this and done the safety uh
survey have actually had access to the
previous
um
issues
in respect of the fact that i actually
asked
what historically had been done there
and i was told there was nothing got the
fact you've got concerns counselors i'm
going to ask it once more and if you
don't give me a direct answer this time
i'm going to draw a line under and i'm
going to make submissions about that in
my closings
you have
no clear and compelling evidence
evidence
do you
to depart
from the considered professional
consensus of the experts at the highways
authority the independent road safety
audit the appellants and the local
planning authority's own mr flexman you
have no clear and compelling or indeed
any evidence to demonstrate that that is
unsafe do you
ever i believe that this what i've done
i've actually brought here i believe
gives evidence to the fact on the layout
that you've got here you're duplicating
what was there before
now we've agreed
that
this
uh proposal is going to return the
dangers that were there previously
have your answer in terms of that and
i'll pick it up with mr blair um sir
uh right
i think
just bear with me a second that's the
final point on that junction so so if
you want to have okay so if we we'll
have a break now it's 20 to 12 we'll
i'll break until 12 give people a decent
break there but uh kind of just before
we do
um you said you've flagged up where the
road safety audit was i was waiting for
an appropriate moment to take a
reference for that
it's so it's in the ta
which is at
core document 1.14
appendix g
appendix g appendix g and um so just in
terms of it
um
just seeing if it's yeah that the the
the rectory road ashingdon road
references is it
page
15
okay of the and it's the stage one rsa
of the ninth sorry the sixth of june
2019 it's page 15. okay i'll look for
that
on that note though i'll adjourn now
we'll resume at uh 12 o'clock so
just just before we leave would you mind
just reminding councillor eve because i
know he's not a professional witness
that you mustn't
yes
cross-examination you can't consult with
any of your colleagues uh during this
break you're you're in purder as it were
or the rules
of residence
yeah you're quite
you you can have a you have a break and
get a drink whatever you can wander
around but i can't talk yep
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
for me
yes
uh not really not when there's no one
else around because they well they don't
they they won't know it's not that kind
of questions
sorry
there's a lady from the council there so
yes yeah
so
[Music]
[Music]
i believe
is
[Music]
10 minutes
very interesting
i
is
one
all right
see you later bye
um
oh
[Music]
um
um
um
um
thank you
yes
so
uh
apologies sir we um we weren't given
access to refreshments until five
minutes ago
the inquiry is resumed then ladies and
gentlemen so
miss reed would you like to
continue have you got an idea of the
length of time remaining for so i keep
tabs on that please
[Music]
about an hour sir okay
well
i'll see how i go i'm sorry it's just
taking a little bit longer it'll be what
it'll be so we'll we'll
well we'll keep tabs on it yeah
obviously we'll look for around about
one o'clock and if you if you finished
or well and good if not then thank you
can move on okay
oh sorry miss philip
just the only thing to say in terms of
timing the
lunch break is there will be some set up
time involved with councillor shaw
getting all the documents ready
so if it's a question of finishing at
100. or say 115 and then we can have the
lunch break to set up council ashore
then 115 might be might be better for
that reason rather than having a break
immediately after council reeves is
finished
well we'll have to see because obviously
if the cross-examination is still going
i may have some questions and of course
i'll be i meant to finish everything
re-examination yes well
i understand what you're saying that you
need some time for council shaw to set
up what she needs so we'll we'll take
that into account when we have the
luncheon german at whatever stage that
is
okay and if it helps on that point as
well there won't be as many documents
for councillor shaw from my point of
view
as there are for councillor eve all
right um councillor eves um so
we've dealt with your road safety point
we've also dealt with junction
one
which is the site access
and we have dealt with
the ambulance roundabout and the rectory
road junction and in respect of all of
those incapacity terms you agreed with
me
that the mitigation schemes proposed
would adequately mitigate
impacts
the next junction that we're going to
look at
is junction 3
junction 3. so you'll recall that
junction 3 is the ashingdon road roche
avenue dallas road
junction yeah yes
and that's the one
where we originally had evidence from mr
flexman
in respect of this two-lane approach
issue yeah yes
um and um in respect of that one
um we have now a statement of common
ground between mr flexman
and um
on behalf of the
local planning authority
and
mr blair
which is the one dated
uh
24th of january 2022
and
what what's agreed there at point b
it's the first point b because as mr
as my leonard friend indicated there
seemed to be it seems to say a b c b d
but it's it's it's the b in the in the
correct place
and what this statement of common ground
says is that the mitigation scheme
detailed in mr blair's rebuttal evidence
volume 5 appendix c
so this was the one that he produced to
deal with the points that were raised by
mr flexman
is deliverable and resolves the issues
that mr flexman has identified in his
proof of evidence and rebuttal
and mitigates the impacts on the
transport network in respect of capacity
and congestion to an acceptable degree
and
the evidence which is appended to mr
blair's rebuttal
shows
um the ratio to flow capacity i think
reducing from 1.10
in the without development scenario to
0.98
in the with development with mitigation
scenario so again that's actually
showing
that the junction will perform better
with development and with mitigation
than it would do
without mitigation and i see you've
produced no evidence technical or
otherwise
to dispute
those conclusions have you
so we can agree then
that the impact in respect
of junction 3
will also be mitigated to an acceptable
degree
and the local authority accepts that
that is what the paperwork says yes
so where that leaves us is that the only
junction
the only junction
that the
where the local planning authority
maintains that there would be an
unacceptable impact in capacity terms
is junction 4. yes
good
now
um
what we also know
is that in terms of your judgment that
the impact
there
would be severe
in examination in chief you were taken
to the modeling
results that had been produced by the
appellant
and you relied upon those to say that
there would be a severe impact so it's
those results that you rely on rather
than anything else essentially isn't it
yes
and um
so
first point um really and it's just a
point of clarification so if you if you
just turn up
um
mr blairs
bear with me a second
yeah
mr blair depend appendices
and it's appendix 14
and it's the table at page 45.
are we talking about this one here
so it's volume two
yeah have that
and you confirmed you confirmed in
answer to my questions a little bit
earlier this morning
that it's the a.m peak that you're
concerned with that you give evidence
about didn't you in respect of this job
that's what i have experience of yeah so
that you
the thing is council leaves is that you
are the person who is giving evidence on
behalf of the local planning authority
your evidence in your proof of evidence
together with your examination in chief
comprises the evidence that you give on
behalf of the local planning authority
you've only drawn attention to the am
peak so the only evidence that the local
planning authority is producing in
respect of a severe impact relates to
the amp doesn't it
my experience regularly
in answer to your question and in
deference to inspector the answer is yes
but i would like to clarify that
in that
the
my experience because i run my business
out of washington and i regularly go
along the road there i use the road at
irregular times
so my experience has been that there
have been multiple times
throughout the day where i have
experienced tailbacks right but that
that's not that's not the question
though counterleaves with respect
because you'll recall and and i'm sorry
but we go back we looked at paragraph
111 of the framework
the test is whether the residual
cumulative impacts on the road network
are severe and what you need to do is
not just look at what the position is
now in respect of the number of vehicles
on the road but also look at what the
position will be
post development
in your proof of evidence which you
confirmed to me set out the entirety
of the local planning authority's case
and
in examination in chief when you went to
page 45
the only evidence that you gave on
behalf of the local planning authority
in respect of a severe impact that you
identified
looking at all of the evidence that's
before you as well as your personal
experience related to the amp didn't it
yes yeah so because you're giving
evidence on behalf of the local planning
authority
what that means is that the local
planning authority is only producing
evidence
that there is a severe impact in respect
of the am peak isn't it
yes but that needs to be qualified in
that i have brought my personal
experience there of that particular time
of day but there are
multiple times throughout the day when
that does actually
get uh severely congested which as we've
agreed is not the point and not what
we're looking at because we're looking
at the position
we're looking at the position
post
development so when you on behalf of the
local planning authority are looking at
the impact of the scheme
you will have looked at the model with
which you have confirmed you agree the
inputs
and the outputs
and the only evidence that you have
produced
in examination in chief and your
evidence relates to the am peak so it
follows doesn't it that the only
evidence that the local planning
authority is relying on
in respect to the impact at the
ashington road hall road west street
junction
post development relates to the am peak
yes but you seem to be hinting that that
is irrelevant though the rest of the
rest of the day is irrelevant no no no
councillor eves you are appearing on
behalf of the local planning authority
which means it is for you the local
planning authority to articulate clearly
what your objection to the scheme is and
to produce evidence to substantiate it
the only evidence that you have produced
the only evidence that you have produced
when you were in your examination chief
when you went to this table and looked
at the modeling results post development
related to the am peak so sorry to
interrupt but miss reed said on a number
of occasions that the only evidence
in councillor eve's proof relates to the
amp and i think it'd be helpful to
go to the particular paragraph that's
been relied on
to say to say that it's only the amp
encounter is proof
sorry the point in terms of his proof is
that he doesn't what he doesn't do in
his proof of evidence is rely on
anything specific does he and then in
his examination in chief you took him
too and he gave evidence specifically
relating to the am peak but that doesn't
matter no no no and the table at page 45
and my point to councillor eves is this
you have not produced any specific
evidence have you
relating to any impact other than in the
am peak to justify the local planning
authority's conclusion that the residual
cumulative impacts on the road network
would be severe
can i just say because obviously you're
you're you're you're you're doing and
throwing
that that to my mind is a fair
reflection of how things have gone in in
council eve's evidence
as it stands the the written evidence
there is no specifics there are no
specifics
in evidence in chief
you did take council reeves to this
particular table
and the concentration was on the am peak
that there was no um
attempt to move to any other areas so
rightly or wrongly i think miss reed the
position as she's summarizing it does
represent the position that i'm taking
notes of here and obviously the
the council's case is as presented on on
by this witness presented by his
evidence and that evidence includes both
the written evidence and matters
explored in chief i mean if it would
help just to give
my perspective on it i'm
very happy if you say it won't but
my own perspective on it is that council
reeves and his proof talks about a
number of junctions operating
above practical capacity in the
assessment year now that's not limited
to either peak and
in the pm peak at function 4 it is above
capacity
in opening i referred to both am pm and
then when i asked councillor eve in his
evidence in chief yes we did focus on
the am but you know there's a time
time time estimate that we stick to i i
hadn't thought that by not asking on the
pm that was somehow
restricting what he'd said in paragraph
4.5 of his proof which relates to both
now let me let me let me check his 4.5
while we're yeah debating that try and
find the right i mean
he's talking about the ta there
he's talking about the ta and he says an
increase in so a number of junctions
operating above practical capacity in
the assessment year with and without the
proposed development and an increase in
congestion with
this mirrors the current experience and
concerns of local residents
that is not saying
that is not saying that he is relying on
that in respect of the point about there
being a residual severe
impact cumulative impact on the highway
network in examination in chief
and i've got the references you very
carefully took him through
the parts of page 45 which incidentally
are not referred to in his proof and
which i didn't object to wouldn't be
referred to
because they came in after the proof can
i finish please and which are not
and which
none of the modelling results actually
are referred to by him in his proof of
evidence and notwithstanding i didn't
object because i thought well i'll let
him expand his evidence appropriately
and he was taken in terms of where you
identified
a residual severe cumulative impact to
the am peak
and i'm sorry and and just to be
absolutely clear a moment ago in terms
of in answering my questions
he confirmed that he was focusing his
evidence on the am peak
and my follow-up question
was that therefore
given that he was his evidence relates
to the am peak only which he confirmed
he did not produce any specific evidence
in respect of any other period
in his proof of evidence
or indeed in his examination in chief
that he relied on to demonstrate that
there was a residual cumulative impact
on the highway network if i could just
very quickly come back on two of those
points firstly i've got to know the
counselor he's i think there's some
confusion here because council leaves
talking about his personal experience so
you know his personal what he sees
there's a difference between that and he
has referred to that several times and
i've noted that but obviously the
the key point that counselor eve should
be doing is putting forward
the local authority's
position
and i think that that's the distinction
that miss reed is making
absolutely but my point is i think
councillor eve's answers are he doesn't
have personal experience on the road in
the pmp i think it needs to be very
clear that there's a difference between
that and him saying
the impact on the pmp is acceptable from
the modeling outputs that he's seen and
just on that
on that there was a criticism that
council reeves hadn't referred to page
45 in his proof and of course page 45
came out in mr blair's proof because
it's the result of the tweaks and the
revisions that council uh not counselor
mr blair made in his proof of evidence
so he councillors could not have
commented
on
um what's on page 45 because it came out
simultaneously with council reeves proof
was it did not yes yeah yes
the proofs came out simultaneously
agreed though it could have been
referred to had had um council leaves of
wish to in in subsequent rebuttal proof
so i mean there's no obligation
there no no i i think that the the the
point is what i'm keen to make sure is
is that i understand fully the council's
case and i can only do that on the basis
of the evidence that the council is
putting forward and in terms of its
factual
information
there's
not a lot in the um
the proof itself and obviously in terms
of figures you're the only figures that
have been
referred to when you took miss uh
councillor reeves in chief
did rightly or wrongly focus on the amp
so i mean i we are where we are
because of sound reasons as it were yeah
all i'd say says that may well be my
fault but you recall an opening
a reference was made to the position
being as bad in the pm peak
um now
no that's that's not evidence though
no no no hang on that's that's not no
hang on but both of you i've i've i've
said a moment ago it's down down to the
the evidence and the only evidence that
i've been
directed to
in the context of this witness giving
evidence is the am peaking table um on
page 45. so so
ev everything i think that miss reed has
done
has been correct there and i i i i i
don't really see how how you you can
easily introduce
specific figures for the pm peak now
not introducing it because
what the figures are the figures it's
just the point that when it's been put
to councillor eves that in his original
proof he only raised the concern with
the a and pink
actually counselors original proof
doesn't only refer to the okay
in evidence in chief yes he's going to
go through the pmp but i think when
we're asking councillor eves based on
the modeling outputs are you okay with
the pm peak i think it's very important
that it's put on the basis not put on
the basis that he has always only been
concerned about the amp because that
that's actually not the case looking at
his proof
again i i accept that point that that
going by council reeves proof he
expresses albeit in general terms
concern about existing levels of
congestion he doesn't limit that to the
am peak i i i fully accept so that was
all my point was that if he's going to
be put to council reeves that he's
always only been concerned about the amp
we should look at power got 4.5 however
that's actually the case or not any
before he answers the question i think
he needs to see that because it's been
put on the basis he's always been
concerned about the amp
can i also
sorry sorry
can i just can i just come back on that
sir because firstly there was a point
taken about well i have experience at
other times of day
my question actually was then well we're
looking at the modeled results and what
i'm interested in in terms of the inter
your your judgment as to whether the
residual cumulative impacts are severe
is what you say about the modeled
results my next point was that the
evidence that he gave the specific
evidence that he gave in respect of
impacts
was related
to related to the am peak only
and he agreed with me a moment ago in
cross-examination and whether my learned
friend likes it or not and irrespective
of the other points is not it's not like
really relevant because he agreed with
me the only specific evidence that he
was producing
in respect of an unacceptable impact
related to the am peak and i have
written that answer down
the next point then was i suppose it was
the same point really which was that it
follows that you you do not take you
have not looked at this information
and you do not take a specific point
in respect of the impact other than in
the am peak
leading to an unacceptable impact on the
highway network do you
no can i also point out i've been trying
to
remind the parties
that i did point out in my uh
first
um
first examination that um councillor
shaw would be able to testify to other
times during the day i did actually say
that during my um
original examination well actually
councillor eves what you said is between
8 and 9 00 a.m and secondly you also
confirmed that you are presenting the
evidence in on behalf of the local
planning authority in respect of
congestion issues
now i just again
to be clear then
the specific evidence that you produce
in respect of a
residual a severe residual cumulative
impact on the road network
relates to the am peak
only you've agreed with that
and that you are producing no evidence
on behalf of the local planning
authority
to demonstrate that the impact in the pm
peak is unacceptable that's fair isn't
it and correct
if not i'll take you i think you're
trying to entrap me i'll be honest
and uh it's it's something that i have
been very clear
that i have actually said um all the way
through that i believe that there are
problems with all the junctions all the
way through i mean you can shake your
head as much as you like but i mean i
have been very clear about that right
we've been through the other junctions
you've given me your answer that the
impacts at those junctions can be
mitigated
you agreed with me a moment ago that the
only specific evidence that you were
like because you know there might be an
impact but then it's a question of
judgment about whether it's severe or
not
you agreed with me a moment ago
that the only specific evidence that you
were relying on in respect of an
unacceptable impact related to the am
peak
you do not produce any specific
evidence
do you
or any evidence indeed in respect of any
other period to justify the local
planning authority's conclusion that
there will be a severe residual impact
on the road network this is what i was
could you answer right okay i'll give a
specific answer and then i'll clarify so
as the notes are are correct
if you are looking at it from the point
of view of putting words into my mouth
then yes you are right but what i have
been clear about all the way along is
that there have been various times
during the day because of the nature of
my business that i go down that road and
i have experienced at various times of
the day
congestion in that road there which has
caused me delay to get to my destination
right specifically along ashington road
noted
thank you
um but thank you for the confirmation on
the point that i was asking you about um
the other just point of clarification
was in in examination in chief you
raised a number of issues in respect of
the impacts of the development which is
what we're concerned about
in terms of the am peak and we looked at
the
aerial photograph that you had
produced
if you remember
it was actually sorry not the aerial
photograph it was the plan wasn't it
which was in the ta which showed the
surrounding highway network
and one of the issues that you had
was in respect of hull lane and the
queueing traffic along whole lane or
road sorry hall road i'm sorry my notes
yeah yes remember
and just just to be clear on that if you
look at paragraph 4 sorry page 45 which
are the worst case
impacts for the am peak
we can see
that um
post development well actually
pre-development on-haul road
in the am peak the maximum rfc
goes from 0.82
that's the baseline top blue line yep
for whole road
to 0.84
and the q increases from 26 to 29.
sorry the delay increases from 26 to 29.
so a three second
delay
and the queue increases there from four
to five
pcus so i appreciate you've got an issue
in respect of the ashington road arm of
junction 4 but the modelling results
demonstrate don't know they that there
will not be a residual
well there will not be a severe impact
in respect of hull road
the modeling shows that but the reality
is different
right but you understand because we
started with this at the beginning that
if you are going to be taking a
different view to the highways authority
the statutory council t that has
considered these matters
you need clear and compelling reasons to
do so you have accepted the inputs into
the model you don't challenge the
outputs the modelling demonstrates
doesn't it that post development on hull
road
on hall road the impact will be
acceptable
again uh the answer to that
because you're putting effectively words
into my mouth has to be yes but
i would contend
on that
that um the models don't actually
reflect the reality and this is the
problem that we have had
all the way through
the the weight of public opinion should
actually show that to you
uh you know what we're actually
experiencing is very different
to what the models are actually telling
us very different
and to be clear again in examination in
chief in examination in chief
the impact that you relied on to
demonstrate that there would be a severe
impact
related to the ashingdom road arm
of that junction in terms of the modeled
results related to the ashingdon road
arm
only didn't it
that was what we were looking at
and so you do not produce any specific
evidence because i know you'll have
looked through these modeling results
very carefully
given that you're representing the local
planning authority
you do not present any evidence do you
to demonstrate that there would be
unacceptable impacts
in respect of any other arm
of junction 4
other than ashingdon road
in the am peak
no but that doesn't mean to dismiss
the ashington road now i'm not going i'm
going to look at ashington road with you
in a moment don't you don't worry but
i'm just understanding so no specific
evidence
on behalf of the local planning
authority
to demonstrate
an unacceptable
impact
on any arm
of junction 4
other than ashingdon road
in the amp
on the basis of the
that's that's where we're at isn't it
councillor eves
i can't comment on that with regards to
the the figures there without actually
consulting with
our council on that but i uh in what
i've actually seen and concentrated on i
have concentrated on the ashington arm
yes
right no i'm taking no it's not about
consulting with mr parkinson so mr
parkinson can give you advice about what
might have been a good argument
it's about your evidence for the
purposes of this inquiry
which where we are at now given that you
is that you rely on no specific evidence
do you and i want a clear answer to this
on behalf of the local planning
authority to demonstrate that there will
be an unacceptable impact on any arm of
junction 4 other than ashington road on
the basis of the modelling that you have
seen and considered that's that that's
right isn't it councillor and in that
case the answer is no
because if you look at the max rfcs for
west street they again
are increased beyond capacity right but
on west street on west street the
rfc increases from 1 to 1.03 doesn't it
and what we are looking at is whether or
not there is a severe
impact you are not seriously suggesting
are you and if so on what basis do you
depart from the local the highway
authority's view that that impact based
on the model's results is severe
that's not your evidence is it
if we are look if we are looking at
one
as being free-flowing
that is free-flowing at the moment yes
there is an increase in the key i'm not
talking about the increase i'm talking
about the actual figure 16 to 20 pcus
i'm not talking about vehicles i'm not
talking about the increase i'm talking
about the actual figure
we're talking at west street is looking
at a rfc of one yes right okay now we're
looking to go to 1.03 now whether it's
1.03 or 1.01 it's still an increase over
capacity
right so it is going to cause a severe
issue
if you look you've got to look at what
that means the maximum pc uq goes from
16 to 20 cars
so you're not seriously suggesting are
you that an increase of four vehicles at
that arm of the junction
and let's
take a point on ashington road and we're
going to explore that in a moment and
that was the evidence you gave in chief
but it's not seriously your evidence
that an inquiry
that an increase in four vehicles
is a severe impact on that arm of the
junction is it
the problem that you have there is that
if you are you only have to have one
more that's actually going to impact on
the other arm
and that is the issue that i have that
is the cumulative effect of all of them
and that is what was actually brought it
out in my first
evidence it's the cumulative effect that
is the issue right so it is not a
singular effect it's the cumulative
effect of that of the in
of all those approaches to that
roundabout that's reflected in the in
the figures
talking about average delay going from
77 to 213
the average so the average speed
street at the moment sorry
yeah
yeah but you're talking about west
street which is 44
seconds to 57 seconds
yeah but what you're missing the point
is that
all three junctions have an effect which
give us a cumulative effect you can't
look sorry what do you mean by all three
junctions here we are
sorry an average delay we've got it at
the point is on the baseline we've got
an average delay
uh as uh 202 not 2029 um a validated
model of the average delay is 77
we go down to the bottom line average
delay
with the development goes to 230. yes
but you've just said all three junctions
do you mean all three arms
functions
okay thank you right yes well in terms
of the impact on drivers on each of
those arms we've dealt with hall road
already you agreed with me a moment ago
not an issue there
we've therefore got ashington road and
west street on your evidence now
where you say there is going to be an
issue so i'm going to look at those with
you in more detail
now in respect of ashingdon road one of
the points that you put
in examination in chief in terms of your
concern
was a concern that there would
effectively be traffic blocking back to
rectory road do you recall giving that
evidence
yeah i should qualify that
yes
i will qualify that though because what
it actually has the effect of doing and
i have experienced this
is that there will be
a queue
but it slows down the whole road that's
what i was actually referring to when it
goes back to the rectory road you've got
a a cue that is detailed here of um
uh
was it 20 uh going from sorry on going
118. now 118
cars
bumper to bumper along there will
actually go
on to the dailies road roundabout right
so we will have a queue on the dailies
road roundabout well that's what i want
to examine with you
because
um
what
just bear with me a second
uh
just bear with me a second
yes
so the point that you were raising
yesterday was a point about um blocking
back to rectory road so i just want to
understand that as i understand it it's
about i think 1.4 kilometers back to
rectory road i've just clarified that
you are looking at 118 cars here in a
queue yeah but what it will do is slow
the traffic up right back to rectory
road okay so you're not suggesting
because what mr flexman says in his
proof of evidence is that
you effectively allow 5.7 something so
i'll allow you six meters per passenger
car unit if you had a queue if you had
118 vehicles max that would give you
around 708 meters
which means that cars would not be
backing or blocking back to rectory road
no i just clarified it no that's fine so
so actually your point is not that there
will be a blocking effect but there will
be
a slowdown in respect of the traffic
from richie road but they on daley's
road on the junction there it will be a
blocking effect
okay
and your
highways consultant who the local
planning authority instructed
specifically
to
defend the appeal has looked at all of
these junctions hasn't he yes
and his conclusion his professional
conclusion
is that
there are no outstanding issues between
him
and between the appellant
and that the residual cumulative impacts
on the highway network would not be
severe
i believe he has missed
this particular aspect so in that case i
disagree with him did you not tell him
about it counselor i'm not in direct
conversation with him am i right well i
don't know
but you know you you and mr flexman
together were giving evidence about
congestion on behalf of the local
planning authority the first point would
be is why on earth was this point not
set out clearly in your proof of
evidence
or your rebuttal if it's a good point
well as uh council has pointed out this
didn't come out till late in the
proof what didn't come out until late
this particular
piece of evidence right that was done
by mr blair you had the modeling results
didn't you
you had the modelling results didn't you
in respect to the ta and the taa which
actually at that point prior to the
tweaks for geometry and trip rates and
growth rates
showed a worse
level or a heightened level of effects
so it would have been perfectly possible
for you to put these points previously
in a proof of evidence or in your
rebuttal proof and you didn't choose to
do so did you
there was no
evidence of this nature
in the build-up
that we saw well didn't you read the ta
and the taa this is not
the what was actually presented to us
this was presented to us late in the in
the day you understand council eve
as a member of the local planning
authority if you are producing clear and
specific evidence and compelling
evidence that justifies departure from
the views of the highways authority
then you don't just read the summary
sheet you need to actually go through
the evidence properly in the ta and the
taa to understand it and there was
evidence produced wasn't there in
respect of
the ratio to flow capacities
and in respect of modeling i have not
seen the modeling results other than
these particular ones here before
well if we look at the
taa
and i don't know how fast but but we'd
look at the taa there was specifically a
table
and a summary as a result of the
capacity analysis
which showed
at that point
yeah with worse results the base case in
terms of the rfc and the queue
development and post development can you
give me an indication of where that is
please
i think the point you're you're making
misread is that this is the taa was
information before the council when it
made its decision
and that therefore the table that's
being referred to was available to the
council at that time
is that i i'll say no more but i just
want to make sure my understanding is
save for the fact that the council
reeves is right that there were then
amendments that were agreed with mr
flexman relating to geometry
um relating to trip rates and growth
which changed the results slightly but
they went down in this table so the t if
the point was going to be made
that the basis of making that point was
in the ta and the taa that was before
the development control
committee
and there is no evidence that sets it
out or details it
in your proof of evidence or in fact in
your rebuttal proof
when you had several weeks to consider
that specific table yeah no i i again
all i want to be clear on is is that um
councillors was saying that he hadn't
seen the evidence until he saw in effect
the appendices in mr blair's and what
i'm trying to be clear on well i am
clear on it but i'm just
verbalizing it as it were
there there was this junction analysis
available to the council
in
the transport
uh in the taa
um
showing actually a worse
situation than this i think that's the
the point isn't it so there there was
scope for the council to have
highlighted that previously so that's
really where
miss reed's been going on this
particular set of questions i think i i
don't want to say anymore because it's
not to me i just wanted to to make that
clarification there so that you
understood that the point that was being
put to you when you said we didn't get
the evidence until late in the day
the evidence had been available to the
committee at the time that the decision
was taken
on this application okay okay did you
read the ta in the taa before making
your decision on the application council
i read the uh the report which is a huge
report um and i thought i had read
everything in there and i believe i had
so
if i missed that particular point
it would have been something that would
not have been pointed out to me by
officers as being important or by the
highways people as being important and i
would suggest that highways should have
actually pointed out to us
in that case on the information that is
there that they could see a problem
with uh backing up
traffic from the hall road junction
to
the
daily's road junction
and i would question as to why that
wasn't actually highlighted in the essex
highways report
well the highways authority have
considered the impact in the interaction
between the junctions
and their response is that the residual
cumulative impacts will not be severe
and mr flexman mr flexman who is a
professional consultant appointed by the
council
to provide evidence in respect of the
appeal on behalf of the local planning
authority
has considered the ta the taa and also
mr blair's proof of evidence because he
provided a rebuttal on it a technical
rebuttal
and he doesn't identify this as an issue
either and his response is that there
are no outstanding issue between the
witnesses and that the residual
cumulative impacts on the highway
network would not be severe so these
points have been considered by all the
professionals councillor eves and you do
not produce any technical evidence do
you to support your conclusion well the
technical evidence is here
the problem that i i see
is that there was a uh a responsibility
to the essex highways to actually point
out this issue are you suggesting
that a queue that goes back
over
the daley's road
roundabout from the hall road roundabout
from the congestion that we're actually
talking about here
is not a problem the thing is that what
i'm saying here is that this is
something that i think is extremely
material
to the uh
to the judgment
of
of our
council on this and it is something that
i think is extremely important if it has
been missed by all of the
specialists uh all of the qualified
people's people on it i can't account
for that but what i can account for is
seeing figures here now that tell me
that there are going to be there is
going to be a problem
where we are going to have traffic
cueing back above
over another junction which and the
modeling has been modeled on
free-flowing which it won't do well i
will ask mr blair about that because
it's a point that you have raised for
the first time in cross-examination
because your point yesterday was about
rectory road
um now in respect of in respect of the
ashingdon road um
arm
down that point in respect to the
ashington road arm of the junction
the
yes the impacts that you were referring
to yesterday in examination in chief
were these points
about the increase
in the
delay
as between the baseline
in 2029 and then 2029 with development
so it's a 665
uh units yeah
so it's effectively
the first section of the blue and the
last section of the blue yeah so it was
the 451 second delay that you were
focusing on in the examination in chief
yes okay
and
you understand that this table
in at page 45 is is a summary isn't it
of the worst case
results within the modelling
yes yeah
and um what we also have
within the proof of evidence
is we also have
um
we also have time segments
in respect of
each junction and in respect of
each
arm of the junction
yes yeah
and if you turn up
[Applause]
if you turn up these page 232
i think there's actually a miss blair
will confirm but there's a typo at page
45 in terms of what what the time is
there but i think that the
on page two three two
one come back this way
yeah that time period is
on
correct
next one
yes okay
thank you
so it's page two three two
um and um what we can see and it says
the time segment at the top is 8 am to 8
15 and i'm instructed that that's the
correct time segment
um and we can see that the worst case
results
that you're concerned about in terms of
that delay
occur within that time segment you see
that yes that's that's the second column
from the right delay in seconds yeah yes
okay and just just to be clear
that is the worst case
um and um do you you haven't drawn
attention in your examination in chief
to
impacts that would occur
in any other time segment
within the peak hours to justify your
conclusion in respect of impact did you
in examination in chief
no however looking back on other times i
can see
that there are other issues
i'm sorry
you again
in your proof of evidence
counselor eves
did not carry out a full analysis did
you
of what was happening in different time
segments nor did you do so in
examination
in chief
did you
no we've been over that ground i think
so
on the basis of the evidence that you
have given in respect to this time
segment what we can see
here
is that
in that time segment which is the one
that you provide evidence about
8 am to 8 15
can you see on the left hand side the
column total demand pcu
yes yeah
so what we can see there is that the
total demand pc use
for ashingdon road
is 240. can you see that i can see that
good
and if we turn up please
page 224
which 224 is
the same
time
segment
but it is
and that the headings are two two one
but this is the base case yeah
yes and what you can see there is that
the total demand
pc use is 215 yes right
so
in order to
take
us back down to base case
so nil detriment effectively
within that time
segment
there would be a need to lose
an additional
25 pcus you see that it's the difference
between 240 and 215.
simple maths yes thank you
and um where
good and so in terms of those
25
pcus
in terms of those 25 pcus
that's the figure and we'll look at
measures in a moment we're considering
but i just want to
take another point with you we know
we know that the site is allocated isn't
it for a minimum of 500 units yes
and
in the planning statement of common
ground i don't know if that one's
actually tabbed up for you
[Applause]
and it's paragraph
5.2.2 please
5.2
5.2.2
we've got that yes and it says this
because therefore because it's just set
out what the allocation is in policy ser
eight
above because the site is allocated for
residential development in the council's
adopted allocations plan
it is agreed that the principle of
significant residential development at
the site is acceptable
so that is the council's
position
as expressed in the planning statements
of common ground isn't it
it is
and because that paragraph is referring
to the allocation at scr8
that talks about a requirement for a
minimum
of 500 units
it must follow that because the site is
allocated for residential development
and it's agreed the principle of
significant residential development at
the site is acceptable
what's being referred to there
is the minimum of 500 units
envisaged by policy scr8
yes what you're referring to there is
seo r8 which was agreed many many years
ago before
the lack of infrastructure improvements
that were taken into consideration as
being part of scr8
were not experienced
that's interesting background counselor
eaves but
the statements of common ground clearly
record the local planning authority's
position
in respect of the allocation and in
respect of the site which is that
because the site is allocated for
residential development in the council's
adopted plan it is agreed that the
principle of significant residential
development so that's the 500 minimum
units we've just agreed
is acceptable
that's the council's position isn't it
that's a minimum of 500 units on this
site
is acceptable and that is what
5.2.2 of the planning statement of
common ground is agreeing to
that is what is written here however i
would
remind you that there has been
significant uh discussion about sar 8
within the council and the expectation
when ser 8 was actually agreed uh was
that there would be significant
increases in capacity to the roads
through improvements which have not come
forward and there are none planned yeah
but the the point is though council
eaves it's it's what difference that
makes to the council's position and the
council's position has been set out
clearly
in the statement of common ground i take
it that you are not trying to depart
from a signed agreed statement of common
ground are you
no no so on that basis and you are
representing here the local planning
authority's position
it is a matter of agreement between the
local planning
well it is a matter of agreement with
the local planning authority that a
minimum of 500 units are acceptable on
the appeal side
this this is a historic
thing that if you're looking at scr8 yes
the answer is yes but you can't give
just a con
a complete yes
to this answer this is something that
has been conditional on the
left take for instance t2
i'm sorry landing policy t2
okay all right we have to actually
look at that and as part of this the
plan the all of this has to be applied
within the the council's planning
policies yes yep
right
sorry sorry so i don't want to get into
a discussion with you while you're
asking me questions because
unfortunately that's not how this works
the
statement of common ground
that is signed and a statement of common
ground this is signed on behalf of the
local planning authority is clear
it is agreed that the principle of
significant we've agreed that means 500
minimum
residential development at the site is
is note the use of the words is
acceptable
that is the local planning authority's
position
isn't it that the principle of a minimum
of 500 units at the appeal site
is acceptable that is what he's written
thank you so that is we can say i mean
if you turn to the front page that's
what's written the front page
1.3.1
this final version of the statement of
common ground is jointly agreed
and then it's signed on behalf of the
council so that is what is written and
that is the council's position isn't it
councillor eve that is what he's written
and that is the council's position isn't
it he's what he's written
can you answer my question please it's
what's written i'm giving you an answer
you seem reluctant to give the answer
be assured i i will note what you say
but the very fact that you're not saying
what clearly appears to be an
appropriate answer will also be noted
okay well the answer is you're here
representing the council
as as the witness on this point
that
okay i'll say no more
okay
i i hate interrupting but it would just
be helpful to know whether that relates
to the principle of residential
development or whether it relates to
it's accepted that the impacts of 500
units on the highway network exactly
don't worry i'm going to turn into that
point in a minute but i just wanted to
be clear
the question was clear
it is accepted in the statement of
common ground
on behalf of the council
that the principle of a minimum of 500
units at the site is acceptable the
council accepts that doesn't it
counselor eves can i just see the
signature of who signed that place
[Applause]
and also mr flexman's evidence because
they say it in their proofs as well
1.3.1 signed on behalf of rochford
district council
i have no idea whose signature that is
and
i would be very surprised if that was
signed by a councillor
what what
country
don't go too far
down this route here we've we've reached
one o'clock so we're going to have a
lunch and a german so so um we'll we'll
obviously have to resume later
but
i i i'm
i find myself here at the moment in a
somewhat difficult position because
what what i'm being given um is a
variety of documents
um and and we're concentrating on
statements of common ground that they
are what they say
they are statements of common ground and
they are signed between the respective
parties
i need to be able to take those as
documents to work with what what i can't
do
is is find that things that have been
handed in and submitted in good faith
are now somehow being questioned that's
that's not how the planning process
works
so i i i i find some of these
interchanges a little bit difficult to
uh to keep up with here okay well i do i
find myself in a situation where i
cannot say anything else other than yes
then
thank you
i mean so if it helps there's no
question of us departing from statements
common ground and it might be that over
the lunch break councillor eaves reads
the whole thing including at the end
that matters with the parties disagree
because i think
it's just a question of whether the
question was do you accept that no no no
no no no no no sorry well no no look
look let me he's let me finish miss
freeze i'm not telling him where you're
going let me hear what mister he's just
let me
it's what i said earlier that there's a
difference between the principle of 500
being acceptable in principle and 500
being acceptable on the highway network
and i think where counselor reeves might
be struggling is which one of those two
has been put to him so leave it there
yeah
leave that there i hope we can
move on
misread what
what stage have we got to on this
particular line of questioning so i can
see when you might be able to get to a
convenient break i don't obviously
disrupt you until you've
reached the end of a topic
right i'll i'll find a convenient place
to break so um
just trying to work out
hopefully in the next five or ten
minutes five or ten minutes okay right
so 500 minimum
units on the site
acceptable in principle that's the label
planning authority's position
if there are 500 units that are
acceptable
in principle
on the appeal site there is inevitably
going to be a degree of traffic isn't
there associated with those 500 units
yes but you have to bear in mind that
this was agreed 10 years ago
i'm not going back on that council
reeves because it is important it is
relevant hang on can you please please
not interrupt me we have just been
through this and you have agreed that
the local planning authority's position
here
now use of the words is in the statement
of common ground
is that 500 units on the appeal site is
acceptable
in principle my follow on point from
that
is that
there will inevitably be
a degree of traffic
associated
with building 500 new houses
won't that
yes yeah
thank you
and if
the position
if the position
is that
500 units is acceptable
as a matter of principle
the traffic that is inevitable
that will occur as a result of building
those 500 units
is also
is also
inevitable isn't it
it's inevitable but that doesn't make it
acceptable well if the principle of
building 500 units isn't acceptable the
inevitable trip generation associated
with building those units
is clearly also acceptable isn't it i
don't accept that no
don't accept
um just so that we have the figures
because what we looked at a moment ago
is that the
in terms of the overall figures so the
base case as compared to the
um 20
uh 29 position with development on the
ashingdon road arm
was that you would need to effectively
lose 25 pcus to take you back down to
the base case you recall that yeah
that's what they did just so that we
have the figure for the difference
between 500 units
and the
662
actually i think mr blair assesses 665
so he's
he's given you an extra
little bit there but we'll take those
figures
and if you look at page 240 please
we've got the total demand in terms of
pcus
for
500 units
is 234
yeah
yes
and we know because we looked at it
before
that
the
total demand
for the
uh six six
two units
that's been assessed is 240 that's page
two three two
yeah yeah so the difference in terms of
the time segment the worst case time
segment that you have
relied on
in terms of your evidence as between the
position for 500 units and 662 units
is six pcus
right
yep you see that
yep
and so in terms of
yeah that's fine
um
and so what that means is that you would
effectively only need to lose
six
pcus
in that time segment
to take you back down to the position
that you would be in if the site was
developed for its minimum
500 unit allocation
you understand i understand it
good
now i think that's probably a convenient
place for lunch sir
and i'll explore the implications with
councillor eves
uh in respect of those points after
lunch okay let's let's just see um how
much more do you think you've got
because obviously we are taking longer
than
your time estimates uh are you still
thinking a similar sort of time for
councillor shaw to what you'd said
because i think it just depends how
quickly we're able to get the answers
that
the questions the support yeah it's just
when we when we started today i thought
we'll get through the council's case
today um
as we're a journey for lunch i'm less
confident of that and obviously that
will have i mean it will be what it will
be i you know i'm i'm i
i need to allow it to take its course
and obviously trivia people along as and
when but um
we'll obviously review progress but
basically two two things i wanted to
know was
one was how much more do you think
you've still got to go with council
reeves well i hope
if i have
straight answered the question no more
than 20 minutes okay but that's
dependent on a degree of cooperation
from councillor eves in terms of answers
to those points okay well we we're
coming up to about 10 past one let's um
[Music]
if we have 50 minutes for lunch everyone
content with uh lunch and german until
two o'clock
yes
seems to be no disagreement
okay i'll adjourn then now um will
resume at
two o'clock um
same applies council rave i'm afraid
it's a solitary lunch for you
[Music]
yes
yes
okay
thank you
oh
um
well the inquiry is resumed ladies and
gentlemen
uh before we go any further uh miss reed
i can give you that um
original set of appendices
back the
version that you
circulated earlier as you rightly said
is not
tabbed but as it's paginated throughout
i'm happy that
if we need to refer to it as as long as
someone gives me the page i can still
find it quite quickly so thank you so i
think we've probably um
more or less passed the
most of this um
cross-examination in the append in the
appendices anyway that's good
okay would you like to
continue then please good afternoon
councillor eve good afternoon
so um where we finished uh just before
lunch was we had agreed that
in the one segment of the am peak that
you
base your judgments in respect of
severity on
we would have to
lose 25 pcus
effectively to take the position on
junction 4 back to base
yeah and six if you were considering the
base to be 500 units yeah
now
just want to be clear
um because you in examination in chief
you made a number of points about peak
spreading trip diversion and sustainable
transport
but you understand that the models that
we've been looking at don't take into
account any of that
okay
yeah did you understand that yes okay
um and so
really those those figures that we've
been looking at are the worst case
assuming that there will be no impact at
all
in respect of peak spreading trip
diversion and sustainable transport
measures
okay
um and
um i just want to understand um how
how reasonable that is not to take those
into account because just want to be
clear
um
is it your position
is it your position
that peak spreading trip diversion well
let's take what peak spreading trip
diversion and sustainable transport
measures will have
no impact at all
on the level of traffic on the road post
mitigation is your point well it won't
resolve it completely
i think i've made that quite clear that
i i do have reservations on that side of
things and that has been um brought out
in my
initial cross-examination yeah no i i
understand that you've got reservations
can we just try and again if we can just
try and focus
a little bit on on the question so the
question was i understand you've got
your reservations and we're going to
have a look at them in a moment
is your position
that peak spreading
trip diversion and sustainable transport
will have
no impact
on the modeled results or is it
that
they won't mitigate those impacts
completely
my feeling is that they won't mitigate
those impacts completely right so you
affect that they will have some
beneficial impact
that is the implication so i my answer
it has to be yes thank you
um because if we
you should have in front of you
um
and just just by way of just have a
think about about those impacts should
have in front of you we had a survey
produced by mrs wright
yesterday can we can we have a look at
that please
you'll have to give me a moment to
locate that again
[Music]
yeah i've got that thank you thank you
and so just just bearing in mind those
figures that we looked at a moment ago
which is we'd have to lose
25
pcus
from the
network so development and on
non-development traffic to get back to
base
or six to get back to the 500
minimum
um if you have a look at
well i'm going to deal with the peak
spreading point first which
is whether people can change their time
of travel to avoid
the rush hour and the period that you're
concerned about
um and if we look at the
survey that was undertaken
by mrs wright and that she spoke to
yesterday
and it's question two on that survey
yes you're there
you have that i have that yeah okay and
so the question that was asked there was
and this is relating to the am peak
which is the one that you're concerned
about
if you are in
sorry if you are a rush hour user could
you change your am time of travel in the
future
to avoid rush hour you see the question
asked there okay
do you see that yeah
and um ten percent of people
well actually nine point six eight
percent of people
said yes they could you see that yes
i'll see where you're going yeah and uh
9.68 of people
are 105
people said that they could in the am
peak you see that yes yeah
so what that indicates what that
indicates is that there is potential
for those 25
trips to be addressed by
peak spreading you see that
yep yeah so you agree that with that
yep can i just clarify something there
the um pig spreading this is what we're
looking at here on the survey that was
done
um is over
the day i presume
the figures that you've given me are
they again over the day because that's
not my understanding well have a look at
the title if you are in a rush if you
are a rush-hour user sorry sorry i'm
misunderstood i'm not talking about
the this is clear the survey here is
clear we're talking about a 105 people
say that over the day that they can
actually over the am peak they say
could you change your am time of travel
am time of travel to avoid to avoid rush
hour okay so the timing that we're
talking about with the 25 that you're
talking about is that over the complete
am or the allotted time
time segment
that time segment of what seven to eight
is that what you're talking about the 15
minute time segment
so we're talking about a 15-minute time
segment as against uh a whole morning's
a sec not a whole morning look to avoid
rush hour
sorry i don't need
sorry i think this is a little
misleading
no no no no sorry i think we're talking
at cross purposes the survey
the survey
if if you are a rush hour user so it's
relating to the rush hour in the am peak
okay because it says rush hour yeah
could you change your am trap time of
travel so it's relating to the am
rush hour period to avoid the rush hour
10
yes
i understand where you're coming from
but rush hour
to some people is different to others so
it could be anything from seven o'clock
to half past nine what i'm suggesting is
that the 25 is only limited to one
particular aspect within that whereas
this particular survey
it doesn't determine a time
sorry
i don't see a time i'm sorry
okay
[Applause]
yes it does actually use okay so
so yes so sorry i don't usually take
what's said from the floor but we can
actually see that um the rush hour is
defined on page one because i don't want
to misrepresent the position
as 7 to 9 30 a.m and the segment that i
was looking at was within that period
but not the entirety of that period yeah
that was a thing
yeah okay so so
just taking that forward though two
points
um the first point
the first point
is that
um
there is potential though because it's
demonstrated here
for at least some
of those 25
pcus
to
come off the network during that time
segment because that time segment is
within that period 7 to 9 30 a.m and 10
of people are saying that they could
change their time of travel yeah i
understood that's fair isn't it and
secondly
in respect to the proportion
of respondents the proportion of
respondents
that indicated that they could change
their time of travel that was 9.68
yeah you see that yes and if you
remember
in respect of the
um pcu demand for that period that was
240 units for that period yes so
10
of 240 is 24. now i'm you know i'm not
i'm not putting to you that this is an
exact science in terms of um comparing
the survey to these results
but what is clear when one looks at this
survey
and looks at the modeled results is that
there is a significant potential based
on this
isn't there
for those 25 pcus
to be addressed
by peak spreading it would seem so thank
you
all right so that's one of the points
next point
is in relation to
uh trip diversion which was a second
point
and we can see
that in the survey
um
just bear with me a second
we can see
there is a question
at question
four
do you ever change your route of travel
to avoid ashington you see that yes and
in respect of that
point
61.47
of respondents
said yes
you see that yes so again
again and again i'm not suggesting that
you can directly extrapolate results and
compare them with numbers but what that
indicates
is that there is also a significant
potential
isn't there for those 25 pcus
to be addressed
by trip diversion as well
could i just say that i think my
understanding of that is that the answer
to
the choices answer yes
they would be people who are doing that
already so they are not people that i
would suggest would be regularly using
that road because they know it's already
a problem so they'd go a different route
the number that i'd be more interested
in myself would be no but i couldn't
sorry would you which one is that sorry
um
when we're talking about the uh the
answers the yes i think would refer to
people who do already
actually alter their route
and i think that that's that's accepted
um but the the figure that i would be
more interested in would be no but could
in the future
the 1.92 because they are people who do
still regularly use the road but could
possibly do something in the future
sorry except that there's a separate
question which is question six which
have you already changed your travel
to avoid congestion so that's a separate
question
yeah
whereas question four
uh do you ever change your route of
travel to avoid ashington
um
and
so that one is dealing with the
potential of people to change their
route to avoid ashington
yeah yeah i think so i mean again as i
say councillor reeves i'm not trying to
extrapolate
results
directly in terms of the percentages to
the number of trips in relation to this
point but what i am saying is the fact
that 61.47
of respondents indicate
that
sometimes whatever that may mean do you
ever
change your route of travel to avoid
ashington
61.47 say yes some people 8.26
say no and then 1.92 say no but i could
in the future
the point is that there is
a significant potential for those 25
pcus because we're dealing with 25 pcus
across the network
in that
set time segment 15 minute time segment
there is a significant potential
for those to be addressed
by trip diversion as well having regard
to these results isn't that i do tend to
read these differently as i've already
explained
if we are looking at a 15 minute time
schedule time slot and this is relating
to a two and a half hour
time slot we could effectively divide
this by ten and i would contend that the
yes answer is people who already
are moving
their route and so therefore are not
using the road when it is already
congested so therefore i would think
it'd be more relevant to actually be
viewing the 1.92 percent where you've
got 23 over the over the two and a half
hours which relates to a considerable
shortfall
of the um
the requirement yeah and and the one say
the one
okay
but what that what it does demonstrate
is contrary to some of the evidence
that's been given is that there are
alternative routes that people can and
do sometimes take to avoid ashington
yes but as i said in my um original
evidence that
the
the problem that you have is that there
is no
ideal uh
alternative routes you are actually
looking at
pretty much what i termed as an
hourglass
uh pinch
at ashingdon road
and so if you want to avoid the
hourglass pinch you've got to go quite a
way out of your way to actually avoid
that hourglass pinch
um now um other points um covered
pandemic things like homeworking i
appreciate the answers you gave in chief
were well you have reservations about
how much difference that can make
um but homeworking use of the internet
flexible working
those given current conditions and the
way that people are some people not all
people are changing working practices
but also has the potential to reduce the
results that we see in the modelling
because we know that the
travel survey that was undertaken was
taken pre-pandemic yeah yeah
it's interesting to note though that um
waze
the
mobile
map
app
they have reported in their figures so
that they have
since the pandemic going against a
baseline of february
uh
2020 which is pretty pandemic
have looked at or had seen an increase
of 114 percent uh in traffic increase
that was actually on sky news in august
right but we haven't got any of that
information before the inquiry have we
no but what i'm saying is that it's
actually
the effect of home working and that has
basically been that people haven't been
at work and so errands etc have actually
come into the equation
but we haven't got that information for
us to look at before the inquiry no no
okay sustainable transport measures
um now um again just want to be clear
you query the potential effectiveness of
them but you're not suggesting they'll
have no impact are you
no but i'm not sure what the impact will
be okay
because if we if we have a look you've
got a copy of the framework
the mppf
on the desk in front of you
thank you
and i'd like you to turn up please
paragraph 105
of the framework
thank you
which is on page 30. yep
page 30 you mean pardon page 30 page
yeah yeah sorry i thought we said 36.
okay page 30
um and um
the objectives in terms of sustainable
transport are set out in power para104
and in one zero five we have the
planning system should actively manage
patterns of growth in support of these
objectives
and then we see this
significant development should be
focused on locations which are or can be
made sustainable
through limiting the need to travel and
offering a genuine choice of transport
modes
this can help to reduce congestions and
emissions
and improve air quality in public health
so just pausing there
firstly it is an express
policy requirement of national policy
isn't it
to focus significant development on
locations that are or can be made
sustainable yes
um and
um
we know that ashington is a tier 1
settlement at the top of the council's
settlement hierarchy isn't it yes
and the highways authority and the
reference is
2.6 of the statements of common ground
with the highways authority
has confirmed
that the site
is highly accessible
yep that's factual
and um equally
in the statement of common ground the
first one
between the local planning
authority
and the appellant
it was also agreed
that the site is in an accessible
location
yeah okay
and so
that first point about significant
development should be focused on
locations which
are or
sorry which are or can be made
sustainable
through limiting
uh the need to travel and offering a
genuine transport mode
is met that particular objective by
focusing growth in a tier one settlement
in ashington isn't it
yes it is
um second point
second point we can see
that what the framework tells us is that
the impact of doing that
is that this can help to reduce
congestion and emissions you see that
yes
so
national policy expressly envisages that
directing growth to locations such as
this
that are sustainable in principle can
help to reduce congestion that is
can have an effect
on the amount of traffic
on the road yeah
can i just be clarified clarify what you
you're actually referring to that you're
referring to public transport and the
likes yes well at the moment we're just
talking about the location of the site
but i'm going to
carry on in terms of public transport
etc in a moment so that's the location
of the site right
yeah
and then um
then we see
opportunities to maximize sustainable
transport solutions will vary between
urban and rural areas and this should be
taken into account in plan and decision
making so that's we're not we're dealing
with
um
that's not particularly relevant don't
think to what we're dealing with here
and then there is support throughout the
framework in terms of encouraging
sustainable transport mode so for
example in power 104 which i referred
you to a moment ago which sets out
um
those objectives
one of them
is to
support
sorry is that development should
um
sorry so transport issues should be
considered from the earliest stage of
plan making and decision
sorry and development proposals so that
um
and then we can see see
opportunities to promote walking cycling
and public transport are identified and
pursued so again in terms of those
measures they are expressly encouraged
by the framework
they are
the fact though is that uh i got a
report which was not in time for me to
be able to introduce him to evidence it
was from the rochefort hundred no i'm so
sorry counselors
no i am going to interrupt you there i'm
so sorry sir i'm not happy for reports
that um no we
need we nee we need to stick to what's
before the inquiry
i'd like to give some context if that is
possible well i i
it'd be helpful if you would address the
questions that are put to you as i said
a moment ago so
it was a simple question which is that
in terms of promoting sustainable
transport
development proposals should
from the earlier state from the earliest
stages of plan making development
proposals take opportunities to promote
walking cycling and public transport use
are identified and pursued so the simple
point is that is an express
requirement
objective of the framework isn't it
yes it is but it's not being attained
it's partly it's not being attained
right well we will look at that in a
moment
now then
next point next point in terms of the
potential
of measures
to reduce the 25 pcus
and reduce
the
highway impact on the single junction in
the am peak in that segment that you
have identified that is of concern
and do you have a copy of the cell
compliance schedule in front of you i
don't know if there is i asked it to be
printed out over lunchtime but i'm not
sure
right well i'm going to just
please feel free to look at it later i'm
going to just read out
a paragraph to you okay um it's in
respect so you understand the still
compliance schedule is the document
that's produced by the local planning
authority
to
demonstrate
that the obligations within the six
section 106 obligation are necessary
directly related to the development and
fairly and reasonably relate to the
development yeah which are the tests for
those obligations being sought
and in respect to the residential travel
plan that's being offered the local
planning authority
have said the following
necessary
the development will have an impact on
the highway network increased use in
modes of sustainable transport will help
to cut single car journeys arising from
the development
this will ease the impact of the
development on the highway network
and will reduce carbon emissions
so just pausing there
just pausing there
your point as i understand it
is that presumably you accept
that the measures proposed
and increased use in sustainable
transport will assist in cutting single
car journeys
your point is that you're not convinced
they'll mitigate them completely is that
fair yeah the evidence is such that for
instance uh the local bus company
in the area have cut 40 routes
in recent times
there was an s106 agreement for the hall
road
development where the monies there went
to effectively
the same
particular
uh area and
that has not been implemented
well that's that's very helpful because
one of the obligations in the section
106 that the highways authority has
sought is a contribution towards bus
service enhancements to improve those
services i presume i presume that's
something the local planning authority
welcomes to assist in maximizing the
potential for residents and proposed
residents to take up opportunities to
use the bus
what i'm telling you is on the whole
road where they had an s 106 agreement
for the exactly the same thing it has
not come to fruition
so
what i'm saying is that what you've got
to bear in mind is that although there
may be conditions there
if there are not if there is not the
demand the bus companies will not
do it doesn't matter how many conditions
you put on it they will not actually
provide additional
uh bus journeys and the likes to
accommodate the s106 agreement
that's proved on the whole road it's one
to be absolutely clear because my
understanding was that the section 106
obligation was
agreed by the local planning authority
um and
um
just bear with me a moment
yeah i mean just in terms of the bus
service contribution
it's
it's in this in the sil compliance
schedule it says bus service
contribution 700 000 pounds towards the
provision of bus service enhancements
along the ashingdon road corridor to
upgrade existing services creation of
new service routes or the prior
provision of bus priority measures
and then it says
it says projects three and four for
being the cycling infrastructure
contribution
will assist by providing sustainable
means of travel for those using bus
infrastructure or cycling infrastructure
now these are contributions that are
contained
in the section 106 obligation
that has been accepted by the local
planning authority and the local
planning authority has said in the sill
compliance schedule that project will
assist by providing sustainable means of
travel for those using bus
infrastructure or cycling infrastructure
it's i presume it's no part of your
evidence to say that those contributions
are not necessary and shouldn't be
levied on the development is it
counsellory absolutely absolutely not
but the problem that we have as a
council
is that the s106 monies are collected
and they're handed to the relative
uh authorities or organizations
um but we don't have any say over what
they how they allocate it and that has
been the issue with all road right and
we i can see the same thing happening
with this one i don't know what
conditions can be
made any more forceful for them to
actually come up with these new routes
etc but it's it's evidently not
happening
right okay so your issue is just one
about making sure that the monies go to
the
um
it's not just that they go there sorry
that they are allocated correctly yeah
sorry that's what i was just going to
say council reeves if you let me finish
speaking
um is just to it
[Music]
is just to ensure that the monies are
allocated to the correct uh
infrastructure but i just want to be
clear if they let's let's just assume
that everything works as it should do
and the highways authority is the
relevant council t and and the um
puts the monies that are
levied through the section 186
obligations towards the stated purposes
you you accept presumably that the
sustainable transport contributions
including bus service contributions
cycling infrastructure
contributions
so
that's 250 000 pounds to connect with
rochford town centre and employment
sites on cherry orchard way as
identified in the rochford cycling plan
and flagship routes one and two the bus
service contributions we've just looked
at
together with the travel plan
contributions and i've read out what the
local planning authority thinks about
all of those
that those measures will assist in
reducing
the number of vehicles on the road
your point is you can't say by precisely
how much
exactly the his the history is such
that that has not been quantifiable uh
in relation to previous applications and
it's
you know pure history
and um just in terms of the reduction
the reduction of
traffic
um on the road as a result of those
measures so a combination of the peak
spreading trip diversion and sustainable
transport
um
measures
they will have an impact
on all the junctions assessed
potentially won't they
they will but the impact will be felt
most on junction 4.
i think we've been through that
thank
yeah
good
and um just in terms of the
um the council's policies in terms of
the council's policies
um if you turn up the statement of
common ground the planning statements of
common ground please
you have that one yep okay good and um
in paragraph four point unfortunately
it's not paginated but under section
four planning policy
4.2.2
um
this is talking about the reason for
refusal now we know the reason for
refusal didn't include any policies did
it counselor eve's
pardon
i'm so sorry the reason for refusal
didn't
include any policies
no
but you have you have indicated
subsequently the council has indicated
subsequently that it relies and this is
just at the bottom
of there's a big list of policies and
then just above 4.5 where it says
material considerations
it says following the case management
conference the lpa have confirmed the
only policies considered relevant to the
reason for refusal are ser 8 t1 and dm
31 is listed above
no breach of any other policy is alleged
do you see that yes yeah and so um in
respect of the council's position and
then not being a breach of any other
policy
that includes that includes
policies t3
public transport port
t5
travel plans
t6
cycling
and walking
and all of those are policies that seek
to ensure and also sorry clt1
planning obligations and standard
charges
and all of those are policies that seek
to ensure that appropriate
measures are put in place
in respect of sustainable transport
aren't they yes thank you so no breach
of those and so um it's also the case
that the local planning authority nor
the highways authority has requested
that the appellant provides anything
else
in respect of sustainable transport
provision or indeed any other obligation
that hasn't been provided and we know
that because there's no allegation of a
breach of clt1 yeah no i think the the
issue there though is that there has
been evidence has come forward since
that i know is not here so it's not
admissible
but it is it has put a question mark
especially on bus provision
and i did suggest that earlier on
the rochefort hundred meeting
did list that there were 40 routes that
had actually been dropped off of the bus
routes in the south in this area um in
recent times and they were concerned
about that
sorry just
i know it's inadmissible but i need to
say it because it is relevant right but
i am sorry i'm just going to stop you
there
the highways authority has
requested a very significant
contribution towards bus service
enhancements yeah yes which the
appellant
is providing
yes through the section 106 obligation
and the local planning authority has
confirmed in a statement of common
ground that was signed
on
well in december
2021
that there is no breach of any other
policy of the development plan alleged
other than those three policies that i
refer to apart from the fact that as i
say i don't recognize the signature
that's on the it's not a counselor as
fosner
i i accept like in answer to your
question yes and i know your eyes up and
all that but you know it is something
that is material interest from my point
of view as a counsellor
i talk to the people in the area and i
look and see the effect of the things
that are happening i see things that you
don't see you don't live in this area
once this is all passed you'll be gone
you won't be worried about the traffic
we will be stuck with it it is something
that i feel in
duty to actually do my best
to try and help you to understand the
headache that you're going to land us
with
i'm sorry can we just focus on the
question that's being asked the question
that is being asked is
there is no allegation there is no
allegation and there is no evidence
produced on behalf of the local
i'll try again
there is no
i'll try again
there is no allegation of conflict that
is being made on behalf of the local
planning
authority
that there is a conflict with policy
clt1
t1
policy clt1
t3 t5
t6 of the development plan and the local
planning authority
produces no or clt1 and the local
planning authority
produces no evidence to support that
there would be a breach of any of those
policies
does it counselor eves
um and um
then if we
um if we um then have a think about
where that takes us
if we are
the local planning authority is not
taking a case that there is a breach of
those policies
and that therefore adequate
contributions have been made
in respect of public transport travel
plans cycling and walking up and
planning obligations in accordance with
those policies
and we also know
that contributions have been made
in respect of highway infrastructure
where it is possible
to implement mitigation schemes so that
was rectory road
um amblin roundabout and the dallas road
roche avenue
junctions we spoke about that earlier
insofar as it is
uh
sorry
yeah if we then look at policy t1 please
which is at core document 6.1
and
just just whilst that's being turned up
we know that policy dm 31 deals with
traffic management and then t1 deals
with traffic so they need to be read
together don't they
what what page in the document i'm so
sorry sir um
it is
tabs format it's page 107.
thank you
and we know councillor that um
that so we're going to look at t1
there's also an allegation of conflict
with dm 31 which relates to traffic
management these policies need to be
read and understood together don't they
thank you
so do you have do you have them yes good
lots of paper
um
policy t1
t1 is the policy in the core strategy
that deals with highways
yeah that's its heading we've also got
dm1 which is in the
um
development management plan
31 which is dealing with traffic
management
and so these are effectively policies
that need to be read together in respect
of mitigations that have proposed the
highway network don't they yeah yep
okay so let's have a look at policy t1
so
we can see the first part of policy t1
is developments will be required to be
located and designed in such a way as to
reduce reliance on the private car now
we looked at the framework a moment ago
and it's a matter of agreement
between us
tier one settlement highly sustainable
location on that basis so it's a tick
for that part of the policy isn't it
complies with that part of the policy
okay
yeah
okay
um
then we see this however
some impact on the highway network is
inevitable
and the council will work with the
developers and the highway authority to
ensure that appropriate improvements are
carried out
just pausing there
the
[Music]
um
the appellant the appellant
has
provided
improvements
to all the junctions where it is
possible to do so here haven't they
because we know that junction 4 is one
where the impacts can't be mitigated on
the ground because of the constraints on
the ground
okay yeah so
tick in terms of that part of the policy
then counselor eves yeah
no i'm sorry i'm not happy about
sir
can hear interjections from people yeah
i i've tried to keep it low-key but i
mean
i i've said several times it's it's a
public inquiry it's not a public meeting
there's no one's been totally disruptive
or else i would seek to have you ejected
and that's clearly uh
an issue that i don't want to get i
don't want to go there
but please respect the process questions
are being put to the witness the witness
is required to answer those questions it
doesn't need
the inquiry doesn't need the assistance
of comments or whatever in the
background comments and noises
can we continue please
so that second sentence however some
impact on the highway network is
inevitable and the council will work
with developers and the highway
authority to ensure that appropriate
improvements are carried out now it has
been agreed that junction improvements
at all of the junctions apart from
junction 4
will be carried out and you've accepted
that those will mitigate the impacts at
those junctions to an acceptable degree
so
we can see there that appropriate
improvements will be carried out insofar
as it's possible to do so
so that's a tick in terms of that part
of the policy in respect of compliance
isn't it counsellor
uh no i don't believe it is the reason
being why is because you've said you've
done it as the improvements are done as
far as possible
and we've already identified the whole
road is an issue
so
[Music]
you see the the thing that that concerns
me is if you skip down to policy to okay
policy t1 is looking at the highway
network yeah policy t2 is looking at
specifics
within the network we are looking at
ashington road
is cited there as a specific issue
that needs to have traffic improve
traffic flows and reduce conduct
congestion it is agreed that the the the
the plans that have come up with and the
mitigation that's come up will will not
reduce congestion
i know that your contention is that it
will actually
not increase it that much but it is it
is a specific thing there in highways
and i do actually i know that you're
what you're going to say there you're
going to say that basically this at the
heart that we haven't actually um
disagreed with this before but it is a
point to note
that this is something which is an issue
the highways yes there's going to be an
impact on the highways but when we get
down to specifics in t2
there is a specific issue that is asked
to be dealt with there that is not
actually um
achieving t2 okay i'm not in t2 yet i'm
in teamwork
we're nearly at the end and what i would
like to do is just try and focus on the
points that are being raised and work
through the policies so we've we've had
a tick in terms of compliance with the
located and designed in a way to reduce
reliance on the private car part of t1
the next part of t1 i just want you to
focus on the wording in in that this
second part of t1 i appreciate you've
got your concerns you've made it clear
what they are i'm just looking at the
extent to which those translate into
policy compliance or otherwise okay okay
so the second point of policy t1 says
this
some impact on the highway network is
inevitable so it's recognizing that some
impact on the highway network is
inevitable there you see that yes yeah
and
then it says the council will work with
developers and the highway authority to
ensure that
appropriate improvements are carried out
now the only improvements that are
possible in respect of the impacts that
have been identified are in respect of
junctions
excuse me
one
junction two is the site access so
junction one
junction three and junction five and
you've agreed with me that the
mitigation at those junctions that's
being proposed is adequate and will
mitigate the development impacts at
those junctions
so where it is possible to do so
where it is possible to do so
appropriate improvements are carried out
and there will be some
impacts on the highway network that
remain at junction 4
but that is contemplated by that
sentence isn't it
some impact on the highway network is
inevitable
the council will work with developers to
ensure that appropriate improvements are
carried out yeah so it's a compliance in
terms of that second sentence of that
policy isn't it councillor eves
i think the point that you're missing is
that this is the reason being for our
whole contention here that junction t4
because of what cannot be done there is
in my mind and in the counsellor's mind
who are on the development committee
resulting in a severe
uh case of uh congestion there that
cannot be mitigated
got that point i'm not asking you about
your judgment in respect of the
extent of the impact i'm asking you
about this particular wording of this
sentence
some impact on the highway network is
inevitable but it's saying essentially
that the council will work with
developers to ensure that appropriate
improvements are carried out well that's
happened here because all of the
improvements that are possible are being
carried out and are appropriate
and there will be some impacts at
junction 4 but those are the ones that
can't be mitigated
so looking at the wording of that
sentence in that policy there is
compliance with it isn't that and i'd
appreciate an answer to that point then
my answer is no
right so which bit which bit of that
sentence do you say
do you say that the development
conflicts with because we accept that
there will be some impact at junction 4
and it is also the case that all
appropriate improvements that have been
identified will be carried out now it
doesn't say appropriate improvements
that are being identified it says the
appropriate improvements
improvements um so that means across the
board it doesn't mean selective
improvements in my mind that is how that
reads
and what you actually got there is uh
the appropriate improvements cannot be
carried out because there is improvement
that is identified that is needed on
junction 4 but there's no no
improvements possible
yeah except for the fact that well sorry
just just pausing there we then see the
council will seek developer
contributions where necessary
junction 4 you've also accepted that the
position will be improved by virtue of
the sustainable travel
matters that will be implemented no i
don't believe so no you don't right
okay
in respect of policy t2 highways
improvements
there's no allegation of conflict with
policy t2
in either the reason for refusal because
there's no policy conflicts at all
alleged there
but also
in the council's
um
sorry in the statements of common ground
with the planning authority which sets
out that ser 8 t1 and dm 31
are the policies
that the council allegedly breached
i had not seen that before i turned up
here and so as i said before i don't
recognize the signature that's on there
i'd be interested to know that who it
was assigned that but i do actually have
concerns about what it actually says
specifically in policy t2 with regards
to ashington road
it a
a specific requirement there to improve
and reduce
and i don't see in any way shape or form
whatever's been mitigated here that is
actually going to be any improvement or
reduction in the traffic issue that we
already have have you read the first
sentence of that policy councilor eves
the council the council that's your
council will work with the county
council highways authority
to ensure that highway improvements are
implemented to address issues of
congestion road flooding and poor
signage and the following will be
prioritized ashington road to improve
traffic flows and reduce congestion
so this is this is a policy that's
talking about how the local planning
authority will cooperate with the county
council it's not a policy that's seeking
to impose an additional obligation on
development is it and i think it's a
mistake because i think that what has
actually come out there and the rest of
the members of the committee agree with
me on this
this is the council's plan you
understand that counselor eve yes i do
right so in terms of the policy of the
plan whether you agree with it or not
policy t2
is looking at the local planning
authority cooperating with the highways
authority to ensure that appropriate
improvements are undertaken in general
terms on the network that is not a
policy that imposes any obligation is it
on development in terms of the wording
of it
i accept that thank you
and the highway authority as we know in
any case agree that the
mitigation proposals that we are
proposing
which in respect of the junctions that i
took you through at the outset of
cross-examination will improve the
position as compared to the baseline
scenario
the highways authority
is content with the proposal
on that basis isn't it
there is a basis that they are content
with it but how you can say they improve
i'm not sure because all of your figures
across the board go up
and if we look at the
highway authority's final
uh position in respect of this matter
and if you please turn up mr blair's
it's his rebuttal proof volume five
[Music]
and it's appendix b
differently
what is it we're actually looking
forward to explaining it's in it's in mr
blair's rebuttal proof
uh sorry and it's volume five
so we're looking at volume sorry volume
five
you have that one
no no thank you
it's one of these emails where you read
it back to front but the the first pages
effects for the highways authority
confirming that they're talking about
the full um proposal 662 because the
page um says that is correct it relates
to the current development proposal so
that's the first page of it of the
appendix appendix b yeah but then if you
look over there is a i just hold it up
so that you can see
what it looks like if that helps there's
a page there
it's page two and it's got the essex
highways
yeah it's got their logo on it
and so this is dated this response is
dated the 12th of january 2022 so very
recently
the date's actually on page one right at
the bottom
there's a tetra tech logo underneath
that there's the email
from mark lawrence strategic development
engineer sent 12th of january 2022 10 11
am all right it's a different page
just on page it's on page two
[Applause]
is that what we're looking at
the dates on the bottom of page one
isn't it yeah the tetra tech uh logo
near the bottom of page one and just
below that there's a date sent 12th of
january sorry what was the date again
saying the 12th of january at the bottom
right at the bottom of kate if you look
at find page one there we go got it
there we go yeah yeah
yep oh that's 10th of january
okay so at the bottom of page one
and we've got the date which is the 12th
of january 2022. got that yep and then
we see this so this is the
um
the view of the officer of the highways
authority
this month
i have reviewed the information below
and i can confirm that the highway
authority agree with the points raised
so that there's some respect for this
mitigation scheme that your
consultant mr flexman
has agreed and then then they say this
it is also key to reaffirm that the
application must also be viewed
holistically
and appreciate that the package of
network improvement measures to
facilitate modal shift
form part of the highway authority
acceptance of the scheme
considering those points the position of
the highway authority remains unchanged
and that the proposed allocated
development does not
constitute a severe cumulative impact
and then if you go back onto page one
thank you for confirmation i'd be
grateful if you can confirm that the
words proposed allocated development
refer to the current development of 662
and then he says that is correct it
relates to the current development
proposal so just the highways authority
there
confirming firstly that the application
must be viewed holistically but secondly
that the package of network improvement
measures to facilitate modal shift
are part and parcel
are part and parcel
of
the mitigation scheme
that the highway authority accept
you see that yes
and secondly that their view remains
unchanged
that the proposed development does not
constitute a severe cumulative impact
and you have no specific
clear
compelling
evidence
do you counsellor
to set against
that conclusion
reached as recently as the 12th of
january 2022. i would contend that
and the reason being why is because uh
two things
um
number one the uh
severe impact impact
is not something that is
down to anyone other than the
local authority
to
declare on that thing that was made very
clear my by the mp
um
and
the i i do believe that we have produced
a particular weakness in the
plans that have been put forward that
will have a severe impact
on the road network
this is something that i believe very
strongly
is going to have a severe impact on this
area
as i said before
you know once you've gone then
you've gone
and we will be left with it and
unfortunately locally we are
experiencing problems here already
and this is an issue that we know will
come back to vitus
and that's based on your perceptions
isn't it counselor as we've discussed is
based on the perceptions and on what
i've seen here in some of the evidence
that has been put forward that was
brought out originally
thank you sir
okay thank you
bear with me a moment please
i've got a number of questions that i'd
got to put to you uh councillors but i
think as the cross-examination has gone
on a lot of the points i've got have
actually been addressed so i'm not going
to tax you with many points
but just let me
um
double check a couple one one of them
that i just do want to be clear on
please
was
when you were taken early on in your
evidence-in-chief
and you were describing conditions as
you
experienced them you've said
a long haul road
you talked about um
traffic backing up along hall road was
the phrase that you used yes
from the um
the roundabout
um and
on on the plan you identified as going
back to what what you what you called a
new roundabout that's one that serves
james street i think was was one of the
names on the plan in that development
i'm not familiar with the names of the
roads going off there yeah
westernmost roundabouts serving the new
development yes correct okay
so so what do you actually mean then
there when you say it was backing up
because i've um
what what time of day you you were
talking about between seven and eight
o'clock weren't you yes there
yeah okay so between
between seven and eight somewhere around
about half past seven i don't go through
there every day and i went through there
today and it was clear
so that was good again i said i don't go
through there every day
and i went through there today a little
bit later admittedly but it was clear it
was clear but this is the this is the
problem you see that it is
something where you've only got one
little thing that happens and it does
back up that is our experience it's a
regular experience of all the residents
in the area so when you say backup
you're talking about what um stationary
queue or are you talking about very slow
moving traffic queue very slow moving
okay i would say um
probably you're looking about five miles
an hour or something like that
and in your perception how often does
that happen then i would say the
majority of the times i go through there
at that time of day
okay
i think the only other
point i just wanted to be
clear on uh was the
the issue that you're saying about
directory
road
and mitigation
if if i if i understood you correctly
there you're saying that in your view
the mitigation or junction improvement
proposed wouldn't be safe or suitable
the reasoning
sorry well yes i was going to say um
first of all just let me get your
agreement that i've understood that
correctly you're saying that in your
view that's not that wouldn't be safe or
suitable that's correct
um
and you you you take that view despite
the assessments that you've been told
have been carried out by several
professional highway engineers both the
highway authority the appellants and the
consultant
engaged to support your case
obviously who is now not not appearing
yes and the reason being why is because
of the history
yes
you've said that several times and it's
a phrase that sort of um
is easy to say but i'm not quite sure
what it means because what i'm no you
don't turn to anything because i want
you to address what i'm saying
what what these assessments have done in
my understanding of it by the uh the
highway engineers who've looked at the
layout now is to assess what's proposed
so
i'm not sure how the history
assists in looking at what is proposed
now
if i can clarify then the reason being
why i cite the history is because what
is actually being proposed as the
junction changes from rectory road
they return
the junction
from rectory road into the roundabout
back to what it was effectively before
yes i'm not sure that they do though do
they because i mean that that's that's
the whole point i think there was a
point was put to you the the the
improvements that are shown now
there's no indication no evidence before
me that those have been um available or
that that's been the form of junction
layout in the past right if you look at
the photographs that were actually
aerial photographs that were actually
produced
what you will see is the white patch
which actually designates the area which
is for drivers to keep off yes you can
see the white line or that white painted
area coming along ashington road coming
from both directions at all times
that paint
is
good
as you come out of retro road
you can see the progression over the
years where that has worn away
the reason being why is because drivers
have used that as a second lane
and that is the reason being why
the island was actually put in there was
to stop them using it as a second lane
you see the the curb yes i know but let
me just pause you there you you're
talking about the splitter island on
rectory road you're not making any
reference to the relocation of the
central domed island on on ashington
road and that's part and parcel
of the proposal now
so i i'm not trying to dwell on this in
any great detail what i'm trying to be
clear on though is that when you say
it's going to revert it to what it was
previously that's what i'm saying is to
my mind questionable i'm not saying for
one minute that some of the issues that
relate to rectory road may not have been
tried in the past but taken as a whole
for the junction improvement there's no
evidence before me
to show that this that it's being
reverted as you've put it to to what was
there previously let me put it like this
then
the improvements that are looking to be
put in
are returning the retro road entrance
into the same
position as it was before
that is cited in the highways report
as being an issue before
and so and the reason being why was
because it was a two it was being
treated as a two-lane entrance
into the roundabout there i don't you
see as they were coming out of the
two-lane entrance there they're
effectively using the route that is now
proposed to actually join the road
because it specifies in the report
that the the drivers were overshooting
the the island yeah it actually says
that now that is the route
it says undercutting i think before i
understand that
going over it whatever you're saying
yeah it to my
colloquial mind that's the same
um but what ends up happening then is if
you actually follow the line that the
cars will actually drive
the the white at the new position of the
roundabout in the middle
is exactly what they would have adhered
to
before
so just by moving the white paint over
all you're doing is actually by putting
is actually putting in the uh the route
that was previously taken that was
proven to be dangerous well i i've got
your response i'm not going to pursue it
anymore i've asked you the question and
you've explained that to me
let me just ask you one more point
though on your
evidence relating to that
junction
i'm afraid it's a case of shuffling
papers here i've got to try and find the
i feel your pain the right one
where are we
here we are
[Music]
right
i think i just wanted to be clear
what you say in your
proof of evidence that 3.4 paragraph 3.4
you're talking about um
[Music]
this junction and the
the last sentence on
the first page of 3.4 appears on says uh
there was
subsequently were a number of safety
issues raised and the two-lane approach
was brought back to a single lane
approach and that's obviously what
you've just been talking about a moment
ago
then turning over
you tell me increasing the approach back
to two lanes
and having two further lane approaches
to the roundabout will merely serve to
increase the danger to pedestrians
and i'm unclear
where that's come from and why you're
saying that when when i've visited there
certainly there's a
um
signal controlled pedestrian crossing
isn't there on rectory road a short
distance away from
the roundabout
yep
and what you've got to bear in mind
you've got a lot of teenagers coming
there to go to king edmund and it is
regularly so
a site that you see they don't use
the um
the actual pelican crossings at all they
uh
the vast majority of them do but there's
a lot of chances
who just take a quick run
to try and cut the corner off
and if they've not got an island there
to get onto it is inherently
making it more dangerous
okay thank you
one thing i would uh just
add
there is that i've asked residents
because i've lived in the area all my
life
i i do recall
a time when that entrance into the uh
the roundabout there was a single road a
single entrance and it was made into a
second uh lane at some point in time it
may have been beyond 10 years ago but
i've asked other residents and the likes
and they've all confirmed but we can't
find historical
record of it at essex highways because
it's too far back
but that's when they originally painted
the island on
to then
bring it to a single lane
so that's why i then say that it brought
it to a single lane but it has then been
treated
similarly as a two-lane one
since that was painted
um because they turned it into a two two
lane but then with the problems that
they were having they
painted the the middle bit
and uh turned it into what was
road wise a single but in actual use
carried on being used as a double which
could which led to the
highways authorities producing the
report they did okay
okay thank you i i don't think i've got
anything further i need to clarify or
ask you council reeves so
mr parkinson have you got any
re-examination of council reeves so yes
i have um
councillor reeves can we start at the
hall road roundabout
and you made a point about the impact of
what happens at hall road
on the dailies road junction i just want
to make sure we
we all fully understand what you're
saying
and i made a note of what you said you
said the modeling relies on free flow
through the junctions the cure hall road
would go beyond daily's road and it
would affect the free flow of the
traffic through the dailies road
can we
just
clarify that so can you go to
and it's page 45 so it's
the summary table in mr blair's
appendices
so
we have
ashington road
am peak
max q 118 and we'll clarify
with mr blair later in the week what
what that means when we say max q
but for now let's take that 118.
and then have you got mr flaxman's
rebuttal proof i'm told that you do
um
it's in what folder
it's in the black folder apparently
although there are a number i think it
is
the mr flexman's rebuttal proof
and once you're there can you turn to
paragraph 2.2.13 on page six
so it should say at the top connect
consultants
i think
health is on its
ground i way
[Music]
i think this was the one that was oh
that's the wrong place holding me if i
remember rightly dude can you help
i believe this is a document that was
lent to me previously
no it's not
um
thank you
right have we got it
yes it should stay at the front
uh highways were battle proof by harry
flexman then can you turn within that to
page six paragraph two point two point
thirteen
yes
so
he says that measuring using google
earth the difference between the
northbound giveaway line of junction 3
and the inscribed circle junction 4
is 410 meters so we have a distance
between the two junctions of 410
meters yes
then at the bottom he's given a pcu
length measurement
or 5.75
so
if we just
times 118
by
5.75
we get
q length in terms of meters on the
ground of 678.5
the distance between three and four four
four ten
and my question is first of all is that
the point you're making and secondly
what's what's the implication in your
view of that
yes it is the point i was making and the
implication of it is that the free flow
that is
required for uh junction
dailies road um i believe that junction
3
[Music]
won't be attained
thank you
um
then
going back to the page 45 summary table
mr blair's proof
um
you asked whether the the road network
needs to be looked at and around and you
quite rightly said yes you've got to
look at the road networking around
um
and
i think you said there only needs to be
one blocking a pipe for the whole thing
to to not work i mean how important and
how much of a blocking the pipe would be
the the outputs that we see here at the
whole row junction what effect would
that have on the wider network huge
uh it's it's the it has the potential to
gridlock the area
as i said before it has the potential to
i didn't hear the word say it again so
it
has the potential to cause gridlock
gridlock
okay and then you were
taken to if we look at the various arms
of horror junction you were taken to
hall road for example and
said you know you didn't have an issue
with that one and i think you said
um let me get exactly what you said
you said it's the cumulative effect
that's the issue
yes it's not a single effect now
can you see the row under the different
arms that says average delay yes which i
think you did did mention i just want to
to pick up on that though so average
delay
and that's across the junction
across the hour as i understand it
77 in the 2029 baseline
and then we go to the bottom 29 with
development 213. so taking the junction
as the hole and the cumulative effect as
you mentioned can i have your view on
the amp
in terms of the impact there's a 70
second average delay to a 230
second average delay would have
it's huge i mean this has been the basis
of us as i've said many a time this has
been the basis of us um
proposing the refusal on
the grounds of a severe impact
on the network
okay pm peak
um you've said you don't have any
technical evidence in relation to
the pmp and you don't have any personal
experiences
we do have though
um
here the modeling outputs provided by
the appellant
um
and obviously what we're interested in
what we what we've got here is a future
prediction rather than
current personal knowledge i haven't
asked the question yet yeah i'm sorry
i'm just going to put it i'm sure it's
going to be a proper one but i'm just
going to put a marker down i
specifically asked questions we had an
exchange in respect of this and i
thereafter confined my questions the am
peak on the basis that the witness made
it clear that he was only taking an
issue in respect of the am peak
yep understood
well i i have my notes that what was
accepted is that there's no technical
evidence relating to the pm peak okay um
i'm going to ask the question and then
we can all
review where we are i need to just ask
the question though to get miss
councillor eve's
evidence on the pmp clarified so it's
going to be an open question council
raves looking at the pm peak
can i have your view
on what the appellant's evidence shows
about the impact on the pm peak
no i'm sorry i object to that question
i do object it shouldn't come through in
that way in um re-examination because it
clearly wasn't a point that your witness
dealt with in chief
or uh specifically in cross-examination
and re-examination as you know is meant
to be too i do i do understand that yeah
yeah um i do understand that of course i
mean you say you had my comments earlier
i'm not going to argue with you no we
can't yeah yeah okay okay that's fine
can we move on then to the question of
peak spreading
you were taken to the survey by um
helen wright
have you seen any survey evidence
produced by the appellant
demonstrating the availability of
alternative routes
or the availability to
travel at different times of the day to
avoid the peak no
okay
now the survey
um period for mr wright's survey is 7 to
9 30 a.m that's the
the um a.m peak in that
mr blair's peak
is 7 15 to 8 15.
how much weight would do you give to a
survey that's measuring a different peak
to the modeled peak what's your view in
terms of the weight that we should
attach to that
i would say it'd be pretty high
so sorry just high in what sense so we
got uh mr wright's survey is modeling
seven
to nine thirty and talking about the
potential for people to the fight
sorry i mean
looking at a wider
time scale i would suggest would be
a
a reasonable
assumption to sort of be judging on in a
survey and then if we look at mr blair's
peak so he's all of these tables that we
have in front of us are based on the
period 7 15 to 8 15.
and the point that's been put by the
appellant is well people would be able
to change their route
uh so it changed their journey time to
go earlier than 7 15 or later than 8 15.
to what extent do you think we can draw
draw that conclusion from the survey
that's been produced by
mr ryan oh i think you said as i
explained under cross-examination was
that
where you're looking at and say
specifically
a question i believe it was
four
yeah um
as i said um i believe that where the
answer is yes yep that is because people
are doing that already yep
and if you're on question four
um
what percentage of people said
that they're not already doing it but
could in the future
1.92
and
do we have any time scale in terms of
when those 1.92 said that they could
change their route and whether
well do we have any times in which they
said that they could do it or we just do
we just not know
well that one was based on the
as was pointed out seven to nine thirty
i believe
and there was
if you're just looking for question four
it's the one the quick question for
yourself
yep
so do we know what
when in the day people would be able to
change their route the the 1.92 percent
well we're looking at
uh between
seven and a half past nine yep
thank you
then
working from
home suggested that well people are
working from home and that could
could have an impact on on the figures
here
let's not forget the date we're looking
at so if we look at the table 2029
baseline 2029 with development
to what extent
and to what extent do you consider
that current working from home habits
are likely or not to
extend to 2029 which is the date that
we're concerned within this inquiry
and i think it will become uh
the norm but as i explained
what actually is happening and this is
the reports that i'm hearing
when it's related
to transport
and this is this is regularly reported
so it's i'm not bringing anything new
this is uh what we're actually finding
is that people are working when they're
working from home
they are doing more errands in their car
so they're doing
less longer journey
journeys more shorter ones and in a
built-up area like this
that's what you can expect
okay thank you
and
then
finally
just on this topic
i
want to focus on how much of the
difference the appellant needs to prove
that these changes will make
can we go back to
um cd 4.09 which is the highway
authority's consultation response on
highways
uh 4.09
can i have some help
see
yeah we'll be
cd4
what is reference please
uh 4.09 cd 4.09
it's
[Music]
thank you
and once you've got there you can turn
to page 12.
[Applause]
okay
and we went to this in evidence in chief
um the junction modeling has shown that
the traffic generated by the development
will impact on the junctions assess that
with the proposed mitigation in place in
partnership with sustainable travel
measures the impact will be reduced to
provide for nil detriment or in some
cases improvements so that's the basis
on which ecc
signed off and said not a severe impact
having
been asked questions about it and given
you answers and been referred to
the additional material that you
referred to
how much confidence do you think the
inspector can have that all of those
factors will result
in
the impact on the hallway junction being
reduced to nil
[Music]
that's no that's not going to happen
the the impact will be there will be an
impact there i mean that's that's a
given
thank you and then final
question on policy t1 which hopefully
you still have open or tapped it's cd
6.01
it's the core strategy
and it's on page 107.
what
so you're ahead of me this time
right policy t1
now
if we just focus on the wording as you
asked too
if you're right that the residual
cumulative impact on the the local
network is severe
can i just have your view on whether you
comply with
or breach a policy that requires
appropriate improvements to be carried
out
sorry can you explain that again yeah so
if we just sorry let's just remind
ourselves of the wording so it's the
second sentence
some impact on the highway network is
inevitable and the council will work
with developers and the highway
authority to ensure that appropriate
improvements are are carried out
now in light of the fact that the
your conclusion is that this development
will have a severe residual impact
do you take the view that appropriate
improvements that a policy that requires
appropriate improvements to be carried
out has been complied with or breached
i
i strongly believe that it's actually
been breached i i've made that quite
clear
if we just look at the wording does the
policy say
do everything you can
or does it say
something else
because you suggested well we've done
everything we can everything we can in
your view does that looking at the
wording mean that you
don't breach the policy
[Music]
i don't see cairn in there
i do see a breach of policy there
yep
did you see that phraseology or words
that affect in the policy
do everything you can
no no
thank you um so those are all my
questions there is one point i do want
to make um
which is more of a legal point um on a
number of occasions
it was put to councillor reeves well to
depart from the views of highway
authority you have to have complete
clear and compelling evidence we heard
clear and compelling a number of times
and you know where's your evidence that
they
didn't look at where's your where's your
evidence we take a view that the legal
position is
you have to give great weight to the
highway authority but you don't need new
or different evidence in order to depart
from it
i just wanted to flag that at this stage
um i think
no i just wanted yeah it might be that
we're saying the same thing it doesn't
have you don't have to point to
something that they've missed it can be
the same material the same evidence but
you just take a different view from the
highway authority and as long as their
view is taken into account that's
perfectly permissible without to find
something that they've overlooked
clear and compelling
it is it is but i always want to be
clear on clear and compelling doesn't
mean new or different obviously you have
to have a complete and compelling reason
but it doesn't have to be based on new
or different material okay and it sounds
like we're in an agreement i just want
you to say black fans okay duly noted
and thank you thank you councillor eves
you've had a long session so thank you
for your
contribution um
obviously we're going to have an
afternoon break now but you indicated
earlier um mr parkinson that you need a
little bit of time for the shuffling
round of documents and additional
so we're we're we're kind of coming up
to 3.35
if if we have a 20-minute break is that
going to be sufficient for the witnesses
to
swap over and have the documentation you
want that would be up to 355.
well i i i
i'm happy to say four if you think that
that we need that because obviously i
don't want people to be panicking around
but obviously we are going to have to
have a review
okay let's do that i won't delay anymore
then let's adjourn now we'll resume at
355 with your next witness thank you
hey
it's time to take your seats please
well the inquiry is resumed so uh mr
parkinson would you well in a moment
introduce your next witness but what i
was going to say is we do find ourselves
in a very similar position time wise to
how things were yesterday but
unless you're going to tell me
differently i think we might need to
take a slightly different approach to
yesterday in that
if if we
if we don't begin cross-examination of
council shaw then we're falling even
further behind from the program that i'd
drafted out what what what are the views
of the parties i i sense you've perhaps
chatted a little about it so we haven't
i've also suggested to cancer sure um
i
i think the position is
where
evidence and cheap is going to take half
an hour 45 minutes to get to quarter to
five
i think it is the same position as
yesterday in the sense the council of
shaw has got
council business this evening um and has
some availability on her constraints but
also i think
thinking to
read there's no way we're going to
finish cross-examination no today um and
it might be better we were thinking to
and have an earlier start
when everyone's fresh and there's no
sort of helping to hold things overnight
which is
difficult the only reason is difficult
with councillors council things in the
evening and whilst council shawn knows
the duties and will comply with the
duties it's sometimes just easier to
avoid any of course yes i mean i've i
have no wish to inconvenience anyone but
i'm also pains to try and make sure we
move our way through all the business we
need to yeah i'm more concerned that you
told me earlier that you haven't got
availability next thursday because if
things are pushing i mean we may claw
time back yeah but if if if we are
looking to moving on next week then
thursday would have been useful to to
have had yeah and that is true and
that is true um
are you flexible on this at all or not
unfortunately not no
um i mean i can i can see but it's very
unlikely
i mean i think hopefully tomorrow we'd
finish councillor shaw's
cross-examination and rule sex party
and maybe start on mr blair
yeah we don't finish highways by the end
of the week in terms of the planning
evidence i've put down an hour
cross-examination because obviously the
focus is on highways
so
we should definitely get to the end of
tuesday i would have hoped
and finished the evidence for closings
on wednesday
so so
in terms of an earlier start tomorrow
one option would be to start at nine
o'clock yes i was thinking so
we had say rather than just half that
nine o'clock and then we claw an hour
back because with the best will in the
world i think once we've completed
examination and cheap what time is it so
it's going to be about 20 to 5.
so
realistically
you know to go after six anyway is going
to be a long day for people and tiring
particularly people that um you know are
not professional witnesses there's no
criticism in terms of but aren't used to
the long days etc in terms of giving
evidence i want to ensure that
councillor shaw feels able to answer my
questions without
you know being late at night
so i think if we started at nine we claw
an hour back tomorrow morning
um and we're not going to be
significantly further behind
than we would be if we sit late and
start at the time i agree with all that
one one thing that we haven't got
um
and this is no criticism but mr foster
you you indicated that obviously not
being experienced as it were in
cross-examining you you didn't know how
long you'd be likely
to need uh in in um putting your
questions to the various witnesses so so
there's an unknown element there i mean
you i don't know whether you you've
formed a view as the inquiries
progressed as to how long you might be
doing a read through on my own it's 45
minutes but doing it in this environment
i think no sorry i think you're you're
talking there about presenting your
evidence i'm talking about the amount of
time that you might want to put
questions too i'm sorry the appellant's
witnesses i've got no idea honestly no
well that's what that's what i mean so
you know um
i can't prejudge that but i've obviously
got to allow you the sufficient scope to
put the questions that you feel are
unnecessary and appropriate and i'll
only stop you if you start straying and
repeating things so there is that
unknown i'm afraid that
i've just got to be conscious of we
can't do anything about it because we
we've got to wait till we get there and
it may be that um you know mr parkinson
will ask most of the questions you were
going to ask anyway and you might not
need to equally you might not ask any
that you want to ask
and just make one point if i may sir
that um it's a bit perverse i suppose
but if it goes to wednesday next week
we've got planning training for
councillors and if we don't go there we
won't be able to sit on planning
committees so
thanks oh you're saying you want it to
go to wednesday or not
yeah right okay let's um let's park that
for the time being just see how things
things go
but yes i mean i i think in terms of
what we do for the rest of the day it
makes sense to deal with the
council shaw's evidence in chief then
break at that point
and quite likely have a nine o'clock
start it
all the main participants are okay for
nine o'clock tomorrow are you
yeah
okay well let's let's do that and then
we'll
take another review when we've got to
the end of the council's evidence
okay well thank you for that so would
you like to then
introduce your witness please
thank you sir um good afternoon
councillor sean good afternoon um just
start by formally introducing you have
you got your proof in front of you i
have
um
right if you turn to her 1.1
um your name is the insurer you're a
member of rochefort district council and
the ward member for roche north and
rural
um you were first elected as a member of
the council on the fifth of may 2016
re-elected again third of may 2018
a member of number of committees
including the council's development
committee
which you became chairman of on the 18th
may 2021 having previously held the
position of vice chairman since 2018 and
you've been a member of the development
committee since
uh 17th of may 2016.
in terms of that paragraph is that all
correct it is okay now i understand
powerpuff 1.2
there's a slight correction you want to
make do you want to explain what that is
yes it does say i'm an associate member
of the royal town planning institute i
was admitted as an associate member into
in january 2019 that should actually be
an affiliate member
okay so we just crossed out associate
and perhaps you can yes please yeah okay
thank you
now
paragraph just turn on then to paragraph
2.3
the
paragraph says that at the bottom the
evidence provides that in councillor
adrian eaves proof
focuses on the issue of congestion
and the impacts of the vehicular traffic
generated by the proposed development on
the the local highway network and one
thing that council reeves passed over to
you if you recall
was this point about the impact um on
traffic between the period of eight to
nine am if you recall that yes yeah can
you give your um personal experience
in the same way he did
um on traffic at that period so focusing
on
any queues or delays and and the extent
to which the traffic's flowing between
that hour of eight and nine
i used junction between junction one and
jack junction three rectory road to
dalys road on a route
on a daily basis monday to friday
between eight and nine i run a food bank
so i have to go that is the route i have
to go to go to my premises to open up
the food bank
um and obviously the food has to be
distributed and that is that we have to
have the whole hole between 9 30 so i
must get there so i had in between those
two junctions at that time i could be
waiting 15 minutes
between those two junctions to get to
the food bank again just to just clarify
the two junctions being it'll be retro
road junction
and daley's road junction 3. thank you
um and then when you get to dallas road
what do you then do i go i get to
daley's road take the first turning on
the left going into rochefort town
and do you do the the reverse route and
if so what what time and what's the
condition then i will most probably
leave there because it opens a half past
nine so i try and get away by a quarter
past nine because i've got someone
running it for me i use back down from
junction 3 to junction 1 to either my
home or i go further
down ashland road to go to essex county
council and again it can to those two
junctions between those two junctions it
could be 15 minutes because we've got
the school
thank you
okay um now apart from from that point
on congestion
um your proof of evidence does two
things as you say at paragraph 2.1 you
present the planning case for the
council we'll come back to that
and then at 2.3
um you you reference the fact that your
pre-focus is on highway safety and the
suitability of the proposed vehicle
accesses to the appeal site
now i've
it's in the statement of common ground
and i i mentioned it in an opening but
we should just formally do it for you
just to
to confirm the position on this so if
you turn to
um section five there's a heading
principle issues and assessment
of councillors
yeah that's what i thought you were but
the thing you just referred statement
common ground so i just wondered whether
i yeah no that's fine thank you
and there's a series of headings there
so we've got a the reduction in the whip
for the payment outside halt farms
infant school
we flick over a few pages
we have b pedestrian safety generally
d drop of parking 12 spaces reduced to
six
and then over on the last page e the
loss of the designated segregated cycle
lane yeah
now we'll come back to
um some of these
points a bit later when we look at the
benefits proposal but in terms of
um your evidence
having seen the new information from the
appellant do you say that
any of these factors are
um sufficiently unacceptable that they
should result in the refusal of the
scheme no no okay thank you
right so let's focus on the planning
evidence then which is what your your
focus of your evidence is on
can you turn to
um
paragraph 4.2
of your proof
everything sorry
yep yeah
and i'm just going to ask you to read
out paragraphs 4.2 and 4.3
section 38
in bracket 6 of the planning and
compulsory purchase act 2004 requires in
making any relevant determination under
the planning acts the determination
shall be made in accordance with the
development plan unless material
considerations indicate otherwise 4.3 in
any assessment of this appeal the first
point to be established is therefore
whether or not the grant of planning
permission would be in accordance with
the development plan
if the grant grant of planning
permission is found not to record then
consideration must be given to the
question of whether there are any
material considerations
of significant weight that nonetheless
planning permission ought to be granted
okay thank you and what we're going to
do is we'll just structure this by
as you set up there first look at the
development plan
and the policies whether they're
complied with or not and whether
um there's compliance with the plan as a
whole
do that and then we'll go on to look at
other material considerations so we
start off with the development plan
you've got your heading there if you
look at paragraph 4.7
you reference policy t1 of the council's
core strategy
yep yep now i think you were here i know
you were here actually because you were
just almost next to me you were here
during the evidence of counselor reeves
and were you listening when he was asked
questions on that by uh miss reed i was
yeah
and in the interest of
saving time did you agree with the
answers that council reeves gave in
relation to compliance with policy t1 i
don't okay
so let's
move on then to paragraph 4.9 which is
site allocation
and i just want to explore that in a bit
more detail
so can you pick up the
allocations plan so
it's cd 6.02
[Music]
uh these allocations planned
yep
thanks
once you're there you can turn to
um yes
okay so this is policy sei southeast
ashington
i'm just going to read a couple of bits
out to you and then ask you a question
so if we look at powerpoint 3.224
um
describes the site accommodate a minimum
of 500 dwellings
and then says
um
the overall site area is 23.5 hectares
to take account of site constraints and
to accommodate the following
infrastructure services and phillips
facilities bullet point one local
highway capacity and infrastructure
improvements
including contributions traffic
management washington road
then if we turn into the next page we
have concept statement
and
if we flick down to
page
75 of the plan there's a paragraph that
says
3.2
and that says
a transport assessment including
assessment of air quality must accompany
any planning application to develop the
site this will examine the additional
transport impacts that the development
of the site will generate actions to
address impacts identified through
transport assessment must accompany the
development of the site or be provided
prior to the commencement of development
now you've heard the evidence of
councilor eves in his
view that there's a severe residual
cumulative impact on highway network
in light of that do you consider that
a paragraph 3.248 is complied with in
terms of actions being taken
to address the impacts identified in the
transport assessment
no
okay
now one of the points made to counselor
eaves is well the site's allocated
and there's
as part of that mr blair makes the point
as well there must be some degree of
acceptance that the impact of 500
dwellings on the highways network is is
acceptable and that some congestion is
acceptable
can we look at the inspector's report
into the site allocations plan to see
what
the inspector who made founded sound was
saying so it's cd
6.14
bear with me a minute please
sorry so i realized i didn't give you a
list at the beginning no i didn't ask
for it either so we
we both remiss there but not to worry
and once you've got there can you turn
within it to
page four
um and there's
a heading issue one
so this is the inspector who's examining
the plans issue and his question is is
the overall strategy for the allocation
of housing etc sound having regard to
the relationship with the mppf the needs
of the demands of the district's
identified and core strategy and the
evidence base and preparatory processes
then if we scroll down to paragraph 22
which is on page six of the inspected
report
um
if it's okay i'm just going to read out
three paragraphs and ask you a couple of
questions so if we start off with
paragraph 22
an underlying criticism is that the
overall impact on highway capacity
across the district has not been
addressed
however the report on the examination of
the course strategy commented at
paragraph 50
that the county council's highway
authority has been involved in the
preparation of strategy and is satisfied
that any impacts on the highway and
transport network can be satisfactorily
mitigated close working relationships be
maintained with county council through
collaborative joint working arrangements
and it remains satisfied that travel
demands arising from future development
can be adequately addressed
in this regard the highway authority's
view is that a district-wide travel
model transport model would not
accurately identify changes to the local
network arising from development due to
the scale of total provision and its
distribution across rochford instead the
use of more detailed individual juncture
models is preferred this could take into
account existing permitted and planned
development transport assessments would
be expected to accompany planning
applications arising from the
allocations
and last paragraph um 24 however there's
very limited detail about existing
traffic conditions in the district and
the dirt of survey information other
than that provided by representatives
there's stress on the network and
residents are sensitive to congestion
the role of the 1013 that rolls through
the heart of the district is
particularly concerned although there
are also more localized difficulties
given the lack of detail evidence about
the wider long-term implications some
lack confidence in the county council's
approach
that said not with giving the general
misgivings there's no technical
information about the impact of
additional traffic furthermore there's
no other assessment to contradict the
highway authority's position that the
network as a whole should be able to
cope
more significantly the scale and
location of development has already been
assessed and determined through the
course strategy and because of that
the
site allocations plan is sound in this
respect so just a couple of points i
want to pick up with you on this
we start off with um paragraph 24
the inspector examining the
site allocations plan how much
information did he have before him about
existing traffic conditions in the
district
well as it says however there's very
little limited detail
okay
and in terms of how how that was to be
addressed if we look at paragraph 23
how did the
inspector examining the plan envisage
that the acceptability of changes to the
local highway network would be assessed
through the transport assessments would
be expected to accompany planning
applications arising from the
allocations to the rasc
okay
and in light of that to what extent do
you think in your view
the inspector examining the plan signed
off on
500 dwellings um at this site being
acceptable in terms of its impact on the
highways network it was very limited so
okay sorry yeah i feel it was very
limited for him okay
thank you
um okay let's put that away
and turn next to the
development management plan policies
which is cd 6.03
this is adopted december 2014
development management plan
and we're looking for policy dm 31 which
is on page 81.
and so
heading traffic management and then the
first sentence says any new major
developments must include appropriate
traffic management measures to
facilitate the safe and efficient
movements of people and goods by all
modes whilst protecting and enhancing
the quality of life within communities
etc
now again in light of the evidence of
councillor eves that there's a severe
residual cumulative impact on the
highway network
can i have your view on whether this
development facilitates the safe and
efficient movement of people and goods
by all modes
no i don't
and in light of that your view on
whether policy dm 31 is breached or
complied with
is breached
thank you
so
taking those three policies
your position in terms of whether the
application complies with the
development plan taken as a whole
i still think it should be refused we
had a look at it and with what we've had
the evidence we had it still should be
refused
okay um
you've then
then reached
quite rightly in your proof so we're now
got 4.11
we look to see
whether there are any other material
considerations that outweigh
non-compliance the development plan
and you turn first to the the mppf
now the council doesn't have a five-year
housing land supply what does that mean
in terms of
the mppf and how we determine the
application
we'll have a torture balance we have the
tilted balance okay tilted balance sorry
tilted balance yeah
so that means that
um permission should be granted unless
the adverse effects significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits is
that correct
no
sorry no
no i know that's i don't sorry i'm sorry
i know your position is that the
yeah just in terms of what the test is
what the wording is
yeah i think i just have what i hope i
just have so permission should be
granted unless the adverse effects
significant demonstrate away the
benefits that's the test paragraph 11 d2
yeah yeah you could take it from me okay
right let's look then at that weighing
exercise between the adverse impacts and
the
positive impacts and to do that can we
open up mr gascoigne's
summary proof although now mr pikov's
summary proof
again just bear with me a moment while i
see you
you're looking
for i think it's tab it should say
summary proof of evidence of warden
gascoigne
of royden not boom
[Music]
[Applause]
now mine has been tab sorry
okay that's fine i'm well
mr hopkins just grabbing it if it's okay
this is the only paragraph we're going
to i can just do the first two but i
think just reading it out
whereabouts are we within we're sorry
we're paragraph 2.14
in the summary
proof 2.14 summary okay um
and
uh mr capricorn says the benefits of the
development and the weight to be
accorded to each respectively is
therefore summarized as follows
council sure i don't think you'll have
it uh mr hopkins is just guessing i'll
just read out what it says the benefits
of the development and the way to be
accorded them respectively is therefore
summarized as follows
and the first one is the delivery of
market housing
um
now
there is this is really for the in
inspectors benefit there's a statement
to common ground on
the weight that the council says should
be given to this it's in the five-year
housing land supply statement common
ground cd 9.02
i know it's a cd but i've got it
have you got it
here
sorry this is the
housing supply and delivery you said
everything's by delivery
[Applause]
so what's the
so cd 9.02
and then within that is paragraph 2.25
sorry
2.25 thank you
um and it says as a result of the short
for and in accordance with footnote 8 of
the framework it's agreed that the
tilted balance the presumption in favor
of sustainable development is engaged
it's agreed that new housing at the
appeal site would carry significant
weight in the tilted planning balance
and come to the short that reflects your
position as well than this yeah okay
and then we'll do the same exercise with
the delivery of affordable housing
it's in the same document but if we go
to paragraph 2.11.
[Music]
given the position on affordable housing
delivery and supply in oxford it's
agreed the delivery of 232 dwellings
because 35 affordable homes at the
appeals site carries very significant
weight in the planning balance and
council's short again that reflects your
position does it yes yeah okay
so
then i want to go on to the other
benefits in mr gascoigne's list have you
got now a copy of the summary yeah and
you have paragraph 2.14
i will have you're about to be yeah i
will have in about two minutes
well hopefully less than two minutes
no all right
i haven't you have brilliant
okay so we've done the first two the
delivery of market housing and the
delivery of affordable housing the third
one is the delivery of a community
building now mr gascoigne said
significant positive weight can i have
your view
on how much weight should be given to
the delivery of a community building as
part of the development
we haven't got any evidence that the um
existing buildings within the rochefort
district aren't being fully utilized
so i don't think there's going to be i
don't give much weight of having a
community building
okay
next one down associated economic
benefits
uh mr gascoigne said moderate positive
way can i have your view on the the
economic
benefits or otherwise of the proposal
if as councillor esa said if there is
congestion on the roads
then our local businesses won't benefit
because drivers will just go straight
past them
so
would you say that
would you agree with mr gascoigne's
weighting say it should be higher or say
it should be lower she said so he should
be like it would be lower okay sorry to
interrupt no no no
um okay
then amenity space recreation space
public space school drop-off point etc
he said moderate positive weight
um
can you on this topic then
um turn to your proof
and there's a section at paragraph 5.2
reduction on which for the payments
outside
could you say again sorry yeah your
proof paragraph 5.25
so you deal here with the topic of the
reduction in the width of the payment
outside halt farming school
and you've said um earlier in your
evidence-in-chief that you're not saying
that this is a reason for
um the appeal to be refused
but can i
take you to ecc's comments paragraph 5.4
and they their comment on the reduction
in the the whip of the pavement can i
could you summarize
ecc's final position where they got to
and your view on whether the reduction
in the width of the footpath would be an
advantage or a disadvantage of the
proposal i would feel it be a
disadvantage because you're removing um
it was six meters already and it's now
going down to
3.25 i believe
we've still got your very young children
running across the pavements
and we also do have
cycle laying there that cyclists do use
and
ecc and rdc want to encourage
people to cycle and this i feel this
would be um could cause various
accidents because children don't realize
that a bike could be coming along they
won't hear it
okay
[Music]
then in terms of the waiting that
um mr gascoigne has given this so he's
given the deliberative amenity space
recreation space public open space
school dropper point etc
moderate positive weight
would you say taking into account those
packages but also taking into account
the changes brought about by the
development
the weight should be the same higher or
lower
lower okay
flood alleviation scheme low to moderate
um is there anything you want to say on
that i i can ask
mr piper
why is that range but is there anything
you want to say on that
no i'll let mr thank you
thank you
then a decision made in accordance with
the plan led system very significant
positive weight
if the inspector takes the view that
actually
this is an application that is contrary
to the plan led system so it's not in
the corners of the plan led system
um
your view on whether
that bullet point would apply or not
first of all
sorry
so if we if we just look at the last
bullet point so
one of the benefits being put forward is
that this is
a decision that's made in accordance
with the plan lead system
and the appellant through
uh mr gascoig and ms pycroft saying that
that should be given very significant
positive weight
in your view does that benefit still
apply if the development is not in
accordance with the development plan
it isn't in accordance so it wouldn't
benefit
and if we look at the reasons why very
significant positive weight were given
can you see at the top of the page
there's two bullet points
um
and the second one starts the delivery
of an allocated site
we're on the same page here so it's the
top of the page we're looking at there's
two bullet points
the second one starts the delivery of an
allocated site can you see it on my
proof or on
the same page that we've been looking at
so it's just above paragraph 2.13 in mr
yup
can you see the two bullet points at the
top
yep the second one says delivery of an
allocated site allowing development to
proceed in accordance with the planning
system would ensure confidence in the
planning system and accord with the
principle of consistency and decision
making
this should attract significant weight
and
looking at the converse position
if a decision is made not in accordance
with the plan led system
what would be the impact on confidence
in the planning system and and
consistency and decision making
so if
if it's
if it's a benefit to um
follow the plan led system because it
improves confidence in the planning
system what would be the effect of not
following the plan and not following the
planned system
in terms of confidence
don't worry it's been a long day yes
sorry let me put it like this i'm sorry
i've got a bit of a brain fog i do
apologize is almost certainly my fault
if if a decision is made to not follow
the plan
do you think that will increase or
reduce confidence in the planning system
or maybe you don't have a view on it i
don't think i'll have you because each
application is
on its own merits okay as it should be
and doing that approach of each
application on its own merits
we've seen the benefits and we've seen
the harms and the harm's been expressed
through council of eves
your view on whether the adverse effects
significantly demonstrate outweigh the
benefits
we need housing which is a benefit
we looked at that which is a benefit and
we need social housing which is benefit
but
as per counselor eaves the congestion
outweighs the gain
and in terms of the test significantly
into possibly outweighs the gain would
you say it's significant and
demonstrably outweighs the gain or would
you not
significantly right um
okay thank you
and let me just go back to your proof to
double check but i think in terms of
planning
side i think the final question in terms
of the impact on the highways network
and the concerns that councillor eve's
referred to
am i right in saying that you you defer
to his evidence you're not calling
separate evidence on the impact on the
highway network i think councillors has
covered it
completely
thank you so in light of that that's all
my questions in evidence too thank you
okay thank you uh thank you mr parkinson
um
in light of what we said earlier
obviously we'll we'll call a halt now
and uh
i'll journey in a moment and set the
resumption time for nine but let me just
double check here
um one of the things i do need is the
attendance list so i'm not quite sure
just over there has do it do we think
everyone signed it hands up if you
haven't okay thank you
so we'll get that done um
mr foster
just so if i can remind you now i don't
need it now but i did mention earlier
yeah
i did mention earlier about those um few
redacted photos that so bear that in
mind perhaps get that tomorrow
yeah that's fine is there anything else
from anyone just an update on the
section 106. sir
i think you wanted a daily update on
progress and it's underway i think it's
being signed
um now or you know over the next day um
so it's it's well underway and um
okay um right well i'll have another
look at the program tonight in light of
where we've got to and what's what's
been said
think on again for for next week
so
is there a general feeling between the
advocates that um
closing
sorry and ending closing the inquiry by
closer play on wednesday is is still on
target
very much hope so sir subject to um
hopefully making a little bit of better
progress tomorrow morning with
councillor shaw yeah
i won't have brown
uh brain fog sorry
[Music]
i like it to be in person i like to
actually
i don't like in writing i like it to be
in person in case things arise that we
need to
to respond to but
let's not
go too far down the track we may sort of
put on a face in the next few days and
be okay and i think so um once once from
my witnesses and obviously the
professional witnesses so if we do need
a few slightly later finishers they
might be able to um
do that and equally earlier starts to
try and
make some time up yeah um okay well i
mean
unfortunately friday no not friday no
long longer than say i said half past
three didn't i said three to half three
but uh
half past three i i would hope we're
done by i mean i can stretch it to four
if need be but i mean i know people will
have distances to travel yes so yes we
do
if i
if i may say so sorry and i made that
point about planning training next
wednesday
though it raised a laugh it wasn't
actually a joke
um
i will ask perhaps to move on whether we
can
okay there are other council meetings as
well okay evening session okay looks
like we may be able to do it sir
yeah okay
well i mean
the way i'm seeing things at the minute
wednesday afternoon would quite likely
be the time for closing submissions if
we have managed to get through the other
business and site visit by then so
the attendance list thank you
um so there was just one further point
um i'm not sure what version of the
section 106 obligation you last saw
so given that that it's now agreed and
is in the process of being signed it
might be sensible just to get you
well i i got what was the 11th of
january 11th of january
certainly wasn't the first one i got so
it was
i have had
well an updated one what what i will do
in the break is i will double check
whether there were any further
um amendments after that date um if
there were cause i know you'll have
looked at that one we can identify we
can provide you with a new one just
perhaps identify where the amendments
are
so that it saves you time in terms of
going through it if that would help
that'll be good yeah
yeah okay
that's the one that came through and
with a few attachments there were plans
and the
travel plan information from the county
council i think when it came through as
an email
but i'll not delay matters anymore now
just double check there isn't anything
else from the parties
no
okay thank you then on that i'll adjourn
now we'll resume at nine o'clock
tomorrow thank you
you